[Musique]
renaud piarroux bonsoir bonsoir nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle signature view nous sommes
en direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement
non
c'est fin c'est compliqué de se
présenter succinctement je suis pédiatre
de formation mais j'ai fait aussi de la
biologie médicale fait une double
carrière donc je suis actuellement chef
de service dans parasitologie à la pitié
salpêtrière pour l'ap-hp professeurs
assurent bonnes universités et je
m'occupe beaucoup d'épidémie et je crois
que c'est un sujet à la mode en ce
moment
alors on va parler ce soir des sujets à
la mode on va essayer de faire le tour
du le tour du pays mais de voir ce qui
se passe la stratégie vaccinale la
stratégie du gouvernement qu'est ce qui
s'est passé les vecteurs de
contamination
les procédures on a le temps on est
ensemble première question qu'est ce que
vous faisiez en haïti
je m'occupais justement d'épidémie
j'avais été à l'époque j'étais à
marseille et j'avais été contacté par
l'ambassade de france qui souhaitait que
je vienne parce qu'une très grosse
épidémie de choléra avait débuté donc le
temps de me libérer quand même parce que
je travaille un petit peu à côté
je suis venu en haïti c'était en
novembre 2010 et ça faisait deux trois
semaines qu'il y avait une épidémie
extrêmement violentes qui frappait le
centre du pays qui était en train de
s'étendre sur l'ensemble du pays et mon
boulot a été d'abord de rechercher
l'origine de cette épidémie d'expliquer
comment elle fonctionnait et puis au fil
des années on va reparler de cette
origine mais au fil des années je me
suis
pris au jeu de trouver une solution et
faire en sorte d'éliminer le choléra en
haïti ce qui est chose faite depuis
seulement deux ans c'est tout un tas de
péripéties qui nous ont amenés à ça
alors le choléra l'époque
vous avez eu quelques petits soucis avec
les certains autres experts parce que
vous disiez que ce choléra avaient été
importées qui s'est passé et c'est passé
que le choléra est effectivement
importés haïti est un pays qui est très
instable et
l'onu a mis sur place une mission de
maintien de la paix reçue par un pays en
guerre mais y avait une mission de
maintien de la paix assez importante il
venait d'y avoir un tremblement de terre
huit mois plus tôt donc l'instabilité
est encore plus importante et tout d'un
coup
on voit émerger une épidémie qui est
d'une violence exceptionnelle c'est la
plus grosse épidémie de choléra du 21e
siècle le 21e siècle n'est pas fini mais
pour l'instant c'est de très loin la
plus importante et elle a commencé par
une explosion épidémique le long d'une
rivière d'un fleuve même qui s'appelle
l'artibonite et tous les gens qui
habitaient le long de 7 ce fleuve
artibonite beaucoup se fournissait en
eau dans le fleuve se sont retrouvés
tombe à tomber malade mais du jour au
lendemain les hôpitaux étaient
complètement
submergée par une vague épidémique je
parle de submersion d'hôpitaux de vagues
épidémiques
ça permet de penser qu'il ya d'autres
endroits où on peut avoir ce genre de
mots
est en fait
l'explication était
banal à pleurer mais extrêmement
triste
des soldats venant du népal
était venu donc avant de partir faire
une opération extérieure les soldats aux
10 jours de permission donc ils étaient
tous là chez chez eux dans la femme dans
la famille en pleine épidémie de choléra
au népal tous ces soldats étaient remis
ensemble embarqué dans l'avion sont
arrivés sur différents camps et dans un
des camps l'un des plus grands les
toilettes en fait étaient directement
vider dans la rivière en dessous il y
avait un endroit où il y avait une
espèce de de creux de dolly nous
les soldats faisait mettre leurs
matières fécales mais bon dès qu'il
pleuvait ça allait dans la rivière et
puis
plus précisément à l'origine de la
flambée épidémique ça a été le
déversement de d'une fosse septique
complète dans la rivière
les nations unies quand vous avez dit
voilà l'épidémie on l'a importée on est
responsable c'est les népalais et ils
vous ont dit qu en face alors la
première fois que j'étais amené à lire
d'abord je l ai dit à l'ambassadeur de
france et donc c'est avec l'ambassadeur
de france qu'on est allé voir le patron
le représentant spécial du secrétaire
général de l'onu le titre et l'ont donc
c'est le chef de l'onu et c'est le
patron quoi à la fois militaire et
politique ça plaît edmond mulet et donc
on est allé voir edmond mulet on lui a
expliqué ça s'est passé correctement il
l'a pas il s'est pas mis en colère ou
quoi que ce soit mais il a probablement
réfléchi deux jours après il marc
convoqué il avait tout son état-major
m'ont questionné et vous vous sentez
bien qu'il essayait de voir dans quelle
mesure
non parce que je disais était vrai ou
faux mais dans quelle mesure j'allais
être capable d'argumenter les choses ils
ont pensé que je ne représentais
peut-être pas un danger particulier donc
ils ont continué continuer sur
leur stratégie qui était de
d'orienter vers d'autres causes
potentielles et de ni nier c'est une
chose mais l'onu dispose d'un certain
nombre d'agents ce en particulier l'om
est enfin là la base c'est la panne
american health organization
et l'eau et metz par exemple a très vite
changé la manière dont ils ont
cartographié les premiers cas de manière
à ne pas montrer que ça démarre et d'un
camp militaire et que ça suive et enfin
que l'on aimé sa fraude et les cartes
voilà ils ont présenté les choses un peu
différemment
il y à encore plus net parce qu'il y
avait des cartes tous les jours ocha
qu'est l'organisation de des nations
unies c'est le bureau de coordination
des affaires humanitaires aux états unis
aux nations unies qui a aussi changé la
légende de ces cartes est il la minustah
la force de maintien de la paix de
mission des nations unies pour la
stabilisation d'haïti a
trouvé une source au gouvernement qui a
pas vraiment été cités qui explique que
l'épidémie avait commencé ailleurs un
autre moment est donc tout ce faisceau
de
d'information qui dévié le le
l'attention de l'endroit d'où d'où
l'épidémie avait commencé a permis de
lancer en fait un certain nombre
d'experts de deux grands spécialistes de
choléra aux états unis qui ont développé
des théories
qui disait que le choléra était liée au
réchauffement en haïti au réchauffement
climatique aux tremblements de terre
maintenant ça paraît complètement
absurde mais qu'il était qu'il avait
émergé de l'environnement alors on sait
que vibrio cholerae la bactérie
est à l'origine une bactérie de
l'environnement mais certaines
maintenant comprend certains variants en
quelque sorte sont devenus spécialisé
dans les épidémies humaine et on les
trouve dans l'environnement mais juste
comme ça des épidémies au même moment
alors il ya un débat sur ce assez mais
ça a permis de lancer les choses et vers
le la mi novembre c'était devenu une
certitude ceux qui disaient que
c'étaient les népalais étaient juste des
des fouteurs de merde où
on ne disait pas complotistes pour ça
j'ai pas utiliser le mot à ce moment là
mais enfin des gens complètement
irresponsable qui avaient des intérêts
politiques ou des choses comme ça et la
vraie explication c'était ce problème
climatique et on en était arrivé fausses
explications la vraie fausse
explications oui et on en était arrivé à
dire que c'était de très malsain d'aller
chercher l'origine de l'épidémie
d'ailleurs ça reste toujours très
malsain de chercher d'où vient le
l'origine des émeutes après un long et
que c'était c'était la faute aux
haïtiens de toute façon parce que ils
n'avaient pas d'hygiène il y avait un
certain nombre de choses qui était dit
comme ça jusqu'à jusqu'au revue médicale
qui
font ou ont fait paraître par exemple
lens est une fiction se désiste vous
voyez que les choses sont les mêmes mots
les mêmes titres a fait paraître un
éditorial disons que cela n'avait pas
d'intérêt de rechercher l'origine que
peut-être plus tard pour des raisons
région raisons scientifiques
par curiosité le mourir c'était le mot
curiosité mais que c'était pas loyal
actuellement de chercher et de se poser
la question de l'origine de cette
épidémie parce que ça entretenait un
climat de suspicion et que ça pouvait
gêner la lutte contre l'épidémie sauf
quand même que en dix ans à d'abord ça
c'était un déni de justice parce que
évidemment il y avait une faute grave au
départ déverser une fosse septique quand
il ya eu des cas de choléra dans un camp
et la déversés dans une rivière c'est
quand même une faute particulièrement
grave mais aussi sa condamné à haïti à
avoir en permanence du choléra puisque
si on dit que c'est l'environnement
c'est pas comment s'en débarrasser
si on dit il a été importé c'est un
devoir de de lutter contre et de faire
le maximum d'efforts et il n'est pas
enracinée dans l'environnement alors on
a des chances malheureusement tout a été
construit sur haïti même quand l'origine
a été le
comprise et d'abord par le le rapport
que j'ai fait ensuite part des travaux
de scientifiques ont comparé les souches
qui ont pu se procurer les souches des
épidémies nyon népal juste à ce moment
là les ont comparés à haïti c'était la
même c'était le code génétique c'est
comme c'est comme un livre il ya 4
millions de lettres qui se suivent il y
avait une lettre de différence avec une
d une des souches d'ailleurs depuis on a
trouvé une complètement identiques
quel qui était qu avait été trouvé
quelques mois avant à la frontière entre
l'inde et le népal donc vraiment une une
preuve qui était fort mais laissez les
scientifiques c'est la communauté
scientifique internationale qui à qui on
m'a fait un cas et qui a démontré que ce
que je disais que mon rapport
d'investigation était parfaitement exact
nous revenons à ce qui passe qui nous
intéresse le locaux vides pourquoi c'est
déloyal d'aller chercher les souches ou
du moins de les chercher le
l'origine de l'épidémie alors c'est
absolument pas déloyale c'est l'argument
qui a été fait en faire en anglais c'est
l'argument qui a été longue scientifique
c'est ça oui c'est dans le monde cette
infection se disent ils avaient ils
l'avaient dit comme ça évidemment que
rechercher l'origine des épidémies leur
point de départ est une partie
primordiale
essentiel de l'investigation d'une
épidémie une épidémie ça servait stieg
c'est il ya un travail à faire pour en
connaître l'origine les modes de
propagation et on prévoir le le devenir
sa séquelle travail qui est vraiment
indispensable à faire et c'est un
travail que je fais depuis des années
des années que 8,19
on a vu passer très peu de papiers ou
des papiers relativement respectable sur
l'origine du virus
ou certains chercheurs certains
scientifiques disaient on ne peut pas
dire que
ça pourrait peut-être venir dans la boue
on ne pourrait pas dire on peut plus
dire ça on ne peut pas lier investiguer
correctement la chose alors il ya une
mission de l'om est ce qui est
actuellement sur place
classé à la finit sa quarantaine cela
dit on n'est pas sûr qu'ils aillent très
très loin dans l'investigation la chose
qui apparaît à peu près clair maintenant
c'est que le pangolin le pauvre y était
pour rien le il n'y a pas assez
d'éléments il ya un fossé trop important
encore à combler pour dire ça vient ça
vient du pangolin bon le
réservoir
initial est très probablement autour des
chauves souris c'est sur le souris
vivent dans des colonies très nombreuses
donc les coronavirus sont assez souvent
des virus qui viennent des chauves
souris et puis dans les comparaisons de
génomes il ya des ressemblances après
on a
trois hypothèses en quelque sorte la
première celle qui a été mise en avant
c'est quelque chose qui serait passée
avec un animal sauvage qui aurait été
donc qui aurait fait le lien entre la
chauve souris et l'homme
ne l'a pas trouvé c'est pas le pangolin
en tout cas la distance était trop
longue on l'a pas trouvée c'est quand
même étonnant parce que c'est
certainement une recherche qui peut être
fait toujours est il que ça n'a pas été
étayées c'est l'hypothèse qui a été mise
en avant mais elle n'est pas été
je veux pas dire que les fausses mais
pour moi n'est pas étayé l est pas elle
n'est pas exacte non plus ça reste une
hypothèse la deuxième hypothèse
vous avez remarqué que ce virus passe
extrêmement bien chez les visons
voilà c'est ça est ce le furet on peut
l'utiliser même comme modèle
expérimental pour des traitements et on
a eu des problèmes de mutation
d'ailleurs chez les visons il ya eu des
abattages même en europe en chine
semble qu'il y ait aussi des élevages de
visons donc nos prothèses c'est que cet
autre
intermédiaire finalement entre la chauve
souris et l'homme ça pourrait être le
vison des élevages avec énormément
d'animaux possibilité de transmission
etc puis la troisième c'est qu'il ya un
labo p4 haouran et que ça peut être une
une fuite d'un labo p4 de ce labo
accidentelle mais assez assez gênant
peut-être de l'annoncé ce sont sa reste
des hypothèses pourquoi ces jeunes on a
c'est gênant pour un gouvernement de
dire et une pandémie et c'est la faute
de main de nos laboratoires c'est
difficile de dire ça
va plus que l'argent c'est
c'est la politique internationale c'est
la responsabilité donc
il ya moi j'avais été très intéressé par
d'abord on m'avait parlé de
de ça il ya chercheurs français qui
s'appelle etienne de chroniques qui est
à marseille et pas du tout allié à celle
qui
travaille à luminy à marseille luminy et
qui qui avait déjà ses devoirs sur le
génome sa femme finalement les seules
choses qu'on a c'est de regarder si le
génome était déjà plus ou moins connus
et il semblerait que y ait des virus de
de chauves-souris que les chinois ont
récupéré qui dont
certains ressemblent et
je peux pas en dire plus loin mais c'est
il ya quand même lu un papier dans le
monde on peut retrouver et pour moi ça
reste
justement typiquement le genre de cas où
il faut faudrait se donner les moyens de
savoir ce qui se passe mais l'om est
face à un grand pays comme la chine suis
pas sûr que là la mission de l'eau et
masse et l' oms permettent d'aller
beaucoup plus loin alors pourquoi il
faut parce que
c'est d'abord il ya des hypothèses
différentes et qui met
qui qui sous-entendent que d'autres
pandémies pour arriver de la même
manière et puis le
il ya quand même quelque chose d'un
devoir de vérité historique une chose
comme ça à faire au minimum mais on ne
fera pas dire que je privilégie l'une ou
l'autre de ces trois hypothèses jeudi
que les trois ont été posées et qu' il
faudrait les investiguer beaucoup plus
je vais vous lire un article d'un repas
un extrait et vous nous dire ce que vous
en pensez
un virus potentiellement mortelle a été
transporté dans une boîte de produits
cosmétiques par une scientifique de
l'institut pasteur l'institut pasteur
fait l'objet d'une enquête judiciaire
sur les conditions dans lesquelles des
dangereux virus ont pu arriver à
l'institut en octobre 2015 de corée du
sud sans que les autorités sanitaires
soit au courant havel mercredi le
parisien un virus potentiellement
dangereux
encore un virus ça arrive souvent qu'ils
aient des virologues qui se baladent
avec des petites ampoules en comme ça
est ce que c'est une procédure normale
pas normal il m'en parle pas quand il
faut ça
je pense que c'est quelque chose qui va
exister assez assez fréquemment le
jusqu'à ya pas très longtemps de
transport de de ce alors ça dépend la
dangerosité et c'est enfin c'est il ya
quand même mais le transport de matériel
qui pouvait être
infectieux
à exister oui pour pouvoir l'étudier
pour pouvoir évidemment d'abord tous les
pasteurs à une collection de plein de
pathogènes et ils ont bien été
transportée d'une manière ou d'une autre
ça c'est dur si maintenant les
conditions de transport il ya des
précautions beaucoup plus importante
c'est normal de transporter des souches
après il ya une manière de le faire
alors est ce que la personne le faisait
de la manière la plus la plus claire
possible je ne sais pas je connais pas
cette histoire le virus soigneusement
rangés dans une petite boîte bleue de
produits cosmétiques et rester ensuite
sur l'étagère du bureau d'un chercheur
de l'institut sans aucune précaution
sanitaire du 16 au 23 octobre bon je
vous dis sera un long article bon après
ça c'est un truc individuelle mais mais
c'est vrai que même si ça sortait d'un
laboratoire pour le coronavirus celui
celui de
lakovic 19 ça peut être aussi sorti par
une contamination à l'intérieur du
laboratoire c'est pas forcément
quelqu'un qui la met sur une étagère
mais il y à il ya toujours un risque
effectivement quand on étudie des agents
pathogènes de se contaminer ou de ou de
transporter que quelques uns transporte
sans prendre toutes les précautions
alors on va faire un petit retour vers
le futur
l'année dernière à peu près la même date
vous faisiez quoi et qu'est ce qui vous
a fait prendre conscience qu'un
coronavirus se déployer dans le monde à
peu près la même date balas sur cette
période là je commençais à faire des
captures d'écran élevé la john hopkins
qui faisait j'avais pas les bases de
données mais au moins faire des captures
d'écran de
de la diffusion du virus parce que à
partir de verre le vin surtout 22 23
janvier on a compris qu'il se passait
quelque chose de vraiment sérieux avant
les chinois avaient beaucoup minimisé il
ya bien eu une alerte le 31 décembre
mais bon on
est là
donc j'étais en train de regarder ça et
quelques jours après c'était le 3
février j'ai été
invité sur la matinale de france culture
pour parler d'épidémie choléra parce que
c'est beaucoup de mon sujet mais aussi
un peu comme un virus et je me souviens
que la question se pose est est-ce qu'il
va y avoir une pandémie ou pas et que
pour moi c'était quand même quelque
chose d'assez probable déjà vu la
répartition ça permet de couper court
aux idées comme quoi on ne pouvait pas
savoir que ça
non mais on pouvait analyser
correctement les données pour
s'apercevoir que y avait plein de
régions chinoises qui étaient touchés
mais surtout il y avait déjà plusieurs
pays qui avaient des cas pas forcément
beaucoup mais c'est l'histoire du
maillon faible et dans speed key qui
gère mal le la crise et
l'épidémie démarre les chinois se sont
en plus on sentait bien quelque chose de
grave il avait un il avait fermé il
avait mis un
confinement total sur ou hors à nos
débuts et puis toute la province du
hubei après il avait amené beaucoup de
renforts pour médicaux pour
pour prendre en charge les malades et
s'était mis à construire des hôpitaux
du mal à imaginer que ce soit pour un
petit truc qui disait qu'il n'avait pas
pris au sérieux et pourtant regardez ça
en disant bof enfin c'est tripette
agrippine est ça c'est un collègue qui a
utilisé ce mot la collecte de la pitié
salpêtrière ont maintenant il est revenu
dessus d'ailleurs on a eu un accident
oui c'est bien avant a lancé le premier
lui est vacciné été vaccinées le 2 ou le
3 janvier en face de trucs donc oui
donc le
c'était évident que ce truc là serait
difficile à maîtriser il y en avait un
autre coronavirus c'était le sarce comme
un celui de 2002 2003
c'était sa vie pas été loin de partir en
bim parce que le il conseille en avoir
dans plusieurs pays mais ça avait été
arrêté par tous mais là bon il était
déjà au début du mois de février il y
avait déjà des cas connus parce que il y
en avait en fait plus beaucoup plus
largement mais avait déjà connu en iran
en corée un peu dans ma vie et c'est le
très probablement déjà en france
donc le petite gripette est parti un peu
en sucette est ce que vous vous rappelez
[Musique]
agnès buzyn buzine
besoin est
10 rebonds il ya très peu de chances que
ça arrive en france mais on a déployé
des petites affiches et de sanitaires
aux aéroports affiche est à 4 tout va
bien les chinois déjà à l'époque
construisait des hôpitaux
avaient un protocole sanitaires très
strictes
il enfermé les gens chez eux surtout
dans les quartiers pauvres de hoffman
pour éviter qu'ils sortent
ils fulminent gay et il y avait des
fumigations dans les rues et notre
ministre de la santé un petit peu
stress émotionnel en choc je ne sais pas
comment elle s'exprimer quel est votre
regard vous épidémiologistes sur un
médecin ministre qui minimisait
temporise les choses alors que toutes
les informations étaient disponibles en
fait elle est pas resté ministre très
longtemps puisqu'elle a démissionné pour
se présenter aux municipales et c'est la
démissionnaire à la mi février
donc
je pourrais pas dire dans le détail ce
qu'elle a dit ce qu'elle n'a pas dit si
c'était important ou pas à ce moment là
moi je croyais quand même qu'on prenait
cela très au sérieux donc non mais c'est
vrai c'est cette démission m'a un peu
choqué quelque part je me suis dit bon
on prend ça très au sérieux mais bon à
ce moment là on l'om est ne parlait pas
de pandémie disaient qu'ils avaient
quand même chose d'urgent et de
d'urgence de portée internationale
mais c'était effectivement c'est un
signe qu'est-ce qui est le plus un mais
moi j'irai plus loin c'est un signe au
niveau du au plus haut niveau de l'état
qu'est ce qui était le plus important
pour le président de la république
garder un ministre qui connaît déjà les
dossiers et qui peut y aller ou
l'envoyer
cette histoire
pas très pas très claire de de photos
s'est pas vu les photos je ne peux pas
vous dire mais sur le candidat de la
république en marche à paris vidéo à
vous de vidéos je ne sais pas
le sujet
a vu moi donc je peux pas le sud et le
sujet et pas celui que
que je vais regarder enfin ça aurait été
une très belle fille je sais pas mais là
c'est peut-être quand même libre en
france abou koné non non non
c'est pas comme ça que j'envisage de
métier
et donc c'était pour moi ça a été un
premier signal assez fort comme quoi
dans une alors que là pour moi ça
devenait assez évident que la pandémie
était en train de démarrer dans une
pandémie qui démarre changer le ministre
de la santé pour parce que c'était plus
important de ce la bataille de paris ça
m'a paru très très décalé très décalé
après donc après après on a oublié
verront
épidémiologistes infectiologues non oui
un aérosol vous connaissez
oui tout le monde connaît les aérosols
d'un député psychiatre qui pendait les
visières en assemblée j'avais le masque
pour social top model qui sert à rien là
et non mais bon c'est ça la rassure
ouais non ça ne rassure pas simple en
trois dans l'état plus tard
les masques au début ça servait à rien
puis après ça servait puis après ça sert
pu puis après on fait les masques à la
maison avec des vieux slip et puis après
reprendre des t shirt pour obliger de
prendre des strips
c'est la même efficacité vous cette
efficacité 0 ouais non mais tout le
monde connaît cette histoire d'image que
tout le monde sait que les masques avait
été n'avaient pas été renouvelés qu'on
avait pas de stock de masques je ne sais
je ne cautionne pas pour autant le fait
de faire une communication en disant ça
sert à rien
c'est peu dans ce cas-là 10 rebonds n'a
pas de masque mais dire ça sert à rien
c'est alors doute le problème dans les
épidémies voilà on voit à fond c'est la
confiance donc vaut mieux prendre le
risque de dire on s'est planté
on va voir on va enquêter etc mais
plutôt que de raconter une histoire dont
on va savoir très rapidement qu'elle est
fausse et donc les masques ça sert à
rien alors je
veux pas dire où le viol n'était pas
connue on sait ne savait pas enfin mon
11 août et bien de la manière dont tu as
été transmis
mais
bon moi j'ai dit pas trouvé que c'était
une bonne idée
revenons aux vecteurs de transmission
donc c'est un aérosol qui se propage
dans l'air les gouttelettes
essentiellement il ya une rémanence sur
les surfaces combien de temps sur quel
type de surface trop pressés comme
question ça dépend alors le bloc dans le
fût du canon mais assad et pendant
quelques années oui c'est un certain
temps non ça peut être
compris plus de 24 heures dans certaines
conditions mais après c'est on comprend
bien qu une surface souliers on peut
mettre les mains dessus et puis ensuite
vers qu'on s'appuie yeux et attraper
donc transmis de transmission par les
mains transmission par les les
gouttelettes distance de plus de
permettre de mettre un dc 8 m oui mais
alors
japonais l'interview japonais ça va être
compliqué ça fait un peu loin mais là on
est déjà à trois mètres et quelques uns
c'est pas mal les yeux les muqueuses oui
pourquoi pas aussi enfin
à ce moment là on est si on prend en
compte tout ça on est dans les mesure où
on a un geste genre un tube à sion ou
quelque chose comme ça sur un malade
c'est un geste qui est très à risque de
l'intubation expiration ce qui laisse a
fait tousser très à risque de deux
transmissions lorsqu'on va faut mettre
des lunettes on met un masque le masque
en canard
ffp2 puis faut mettre la sueur blues etc
mais sinon faut quand même rester les
lunettes plus qu une visière la visière
ça sert à rien la visière ce qui passe
de sousse
donc donc les masques alors on va le
faire rapidement parce que ouais ça tu
les masques ffp2 ça sert ça sert pas oui
non bon on a deux
si vous avez vu je suis venu avec la
main sur un masque en tissu sain et en
plus avec la barbe donc avec la barbe
1 j'ai déjà fait la coved donc
pour cela commence et une manifestation
démagogique de la fièvre
tragiquement rien eu mais bon je suis
parti en mission en guyane en plein pic
épidémique j'ai vu du monde même en
portant masque bon c'est pas en faisant
le faut mais on peut le prendre quand
même ce type de masque vous aviez sur
place masque chirurgical
on va pas vivre un orgueil and avec un
masque canard dans la rue et la barbe ça
sert à rien et donc j'aurais pu la raser
mais enfin c met donc le faux pas quand
même trop trop faire de
on peut pas complètement changé notre
vie un certain nombre de précautions
faire des précautions ce qu'elles soient
raisonnables le masque ffp2 chirurgicale
sincère 90 % vs voilà c'est
c'est quand on est dans un espace fermé
quand
une rue où il ya beaucoup de passage
après pour aller sur des grands
trottoirs des choses comme ça c'est déjà
même plus le plus vraiment le problème
et puis comme c'est très compliqué à
expliquer vous le mettre à cet endroit
peut pas le mettre tellement bon ils ont
décidé de le mettre partout mais c'est
quand même pas le smic en extérieur
c'est la transmission faut être proches
les uns des autres on va bien vient
d'imposer le ffp2 dans les lieux cloud
les allemands y sont un peu plus futé
que nous sommes juste de stocks on
change
problème pour l'instant c'est alors le
n'a pas vraiment
il ya ce nouveau variant ce deal est
plus contagieux etc mais pour l'instant
son tout ce qu'on a comme information
c'est qu'il a le même mode de droite et
il va faire les variants après donc le
fmi grimé en allemagne maintenant c'est
pas en hassanya si c'est maintenant et
c'est sakozy variant de ffp un dessert
le ffp2 bien entendu le fait plus 3 ans
et six ans soit le
liste l'histoire c'est le de
les masquer le masque en canard tout
s'arrose on a du mal à respirer dedans
on respire bien nous nous
y en a qui se plaint il y en a un qui se
plaint mais on a quand même un peu de
mal à respirer enfin c'est comme vous
voulez vous c'est mais bon
ensemble tout le temps
familial oui mais
vous êtes très prudent il est toujours
très prudents et bien vous êtes très
prudents et ne recommande pas nos à
l'hôpital
pour les gens qui ne sont pas
directement à faire un soin particulier
aux malades parce que vous n'avez pas de
stock parce que sincèrement c'est parce
que c'est
jusqu'à présent ça pourrait peut-être si
les variantes deviennent de plus en plus
contagieux ça peut être révisée mais
jusqu'à présent il n'a pas été considéré
qu'il était nécessaire de mettre autre
chose qu'à ma chirurgicale quand on se
trouve dans
si on a si on fait pas un geste si on
n'est pas tout près d'eux du malade à ce
moment là on en a pas pas forcément
besoin le masque reus clip je ne sers à
quelque chose de masquer un vieux slip
bon vieux t-shirt pour moi enfin d'abord
c'est pas il ya entre les deux il ya
quand même des masques en tissu
homologués ont recommandé par la dgec ça
oui c'est ça il ya un certain nombre
donc cela
pour se promener dans la rue ça va quoi
maintenant elles sont recommandées par
la dge oui d'accord mais se fait à la
maison avec les vieux slip
c'est parti pour avec des vieux slip
non non non il faut il faut
effectivement quand même être être sur
quelque chose qui a été testé qui
correspond à une certaine norme vous
voyez la police utiliser leur tour de
cou en petit licra kotone molto ni en
guise de masque les ai pas vus je les
croise pas souvent ah oui vous avez de
la chance
imaginez 20,1
imaginez vous un tour de cou en lycra de
vététistes wimy sur le nez ça sert à
quelque chose ça sert à rien c'était
assez dur ça devient de moins en moins
protecteur d'accord
n'ont passé c'est un truc relatifs à
donc effectivement on peut se mettre ans
44 forme aussi le métro le métro ouais
le métro le rer imaginez-vous là on
prend le métro ensemble on va châtelet
les halles rer b rer ligne 13 la ligne
13 super xiii génial ccc c'est bien ça
alors le métro ont fait en effet dans ce
cadre en scaphandre lé dimanche
également il faudrait
plus de télétravail moins de monde dans
le métro plus de ram de manière à ce que
les gens soient pas collé serré
sur le bout comme on dit à mayotte oui
vous avez terminé advenant que c'était
aux comores havas est lui même la même
expression
ils ont pas les mêmes moeurs et une
république islamique quand même mais
enfin bon
donc que le
donc le métro le métro balle
alors c'est typiquement un truc où on ne
l'a jamais de clusters dans le métro
est-ce qu'on n'a pas assez de gens pour
enquêter non parce que en fait on sait
jamais qu avec qui on était en phase
donc quand on la méthodologie même des
enquêtes c'est avec qui vous avez été
tout ça et puis quand la voix afin non
le métro est pas et pas forcément un
risque
c'est c'est compliqué de savoir quelle
est la transmission qui se fait dans le
métro dont ça que cédric ou un fût une
application tout senti qu vide oui à
détecter quoi qu'elle cherchait en mode
alliance je peux passer
détient vitre en canard je me souviens
plus qu'ils ont le nombre de messages
ces quelques dizaines de milliers les
salles les salles de cinéma tout ça
le théâtre en présentant en pleine
épidémie comme ça
on a intérêt quand même à calmer le jeu
et
éviter même des risques qu'on pourrait
dire modéré quand on est face à un mur
épidémique qui nous on arrive dessus en
klaxonnant en plus on a vraiment intérêt
à limiter les les moments où on peut se
contaminer alors ça pose des questions
sur le couvre-feu de 18h 20h parce que
finalement est-ce qu'on se contaminaient
plus en faisant un apéro de 18 à 20
heures ou est-ce qu'on se contaminent
plus en soute à 100 dans le métro de 17
à 18 heures c'est quelque chose qui peut
être discuté je pense que c'est kif kif
c'est statu quo
et mais c'est le
genre de situation là on a besoin de
limiter au maximum les risques
les risques de transmission dans notre
vie quotidienne
donc vous je peux pas dire là maintenant
tiens on va ouvrir les les cinémas même
si en faisant un protocole bien comme il
faut on peut on peut limiter la
transmission
il ya quand même l'attendre devant les
cinémas a quand même il ya plein
d'occasions où on peut se contaminer si
on se regroupe quand la quête le
magazine vous connaissez l'académie de
médecine oui un peu quand l'académie de
médecine
fait des recommandations de se taire
dans le métro pour éviter de propager
les variantes c'est une académie de
médecine qui devenu une académie du
gouvernement et les oem politique qui
suit le fait de ne pas paniquer et de
faire fonctionner l'économie ou si une
académie de médecine
qui est devenu
sous paul est aussi pertinente qu'un
filet d'eau tier 2 qu'est ce que c'est
il faut quand même le vouloir de dire où
jean jaurès j'aurais pas fait cette
cette proposition si j'avais compris que
ces gens ils vont virer enfin ces gens
n'y vont être virés n'a rien pour faire
ce type de recommandation pourquoi le
virer pour faire ce type de
recommandation pour la recommandation et
elle est même pas officiel et non ce
n'est pas une recommandation officielle
c'est enfin une face à une
recommandation on peut la suivre ou pas
la suivre on peut décider de parler ou
pas parler pour passer pour des guignols
à faire ce type de recommandation et non
c'est pas moi c'est pas mon sujet
d'accord donc ne pas parler dans le
métro c'est une bonne recommandation
surtout quand on a des visées balladur
qui ne s'est pas la recommandation que
j'aurais fait vous auriez fait quoi
comment comment j'aurais rien dit
alors je continue à rien dire là-dessus
ok
revenons sur les bateaux de croisière
oui vous vous rappelez les bateaux de
croisières au départ y avait dix cas
mais ça est remis en selle par ailleurs
par exemple oui ça a commencé avec 10 15
48 après c'est un mini 700 cas
ça venait de quoi ça venait qu'en fait
ils s'étaient tous contaminés avant et
qu'on a compris comment les tester ça
venait du fait qu'ils étaient confinés
dans des petites chambres avec des
gaines d'aération qui communiquait avec
les autres champs et donc c'est un peu
mais ça fait compte tenu du coche la
case b c'est les gaines d'aération
option b oui c'est ça les coursives les
gaines d'aération je sais pas mais ça
s'est fait progressivement parce que on
l'a vu augmenter progressivement on
aurait eu quelque chose une courbe
épidémique différente si ç'avait été une
source unique et qu'on revient au
choléra le choléra les gens se sont donc
tout début du choléra haïti les gens se
sont contaminées le même jour en buvant
l'eau du fleuve et à ce moment là on est
dans un espace de pique énorme et puis
ensuite ça ça diminue puis ensuite
l'épidémie propre revendique démarre
s'il y avait eu quelque chose comme ça
dans le bateau en orissa et puis quelque
chose mais non ça a commencé comme ça
donc la transmission a continué petit à
petit avec des gens asymptomatiques
alors je peux pas les vivres sur ce
bateau je parlais détails mais on a fini
par se dire que les circuits d'aération
devait aussi bien participé à la
transmission parce que des gens disent
ont été contaminées je suis pas sorti de
ma cabine pendant six jours les cds
c'était une amérique de le confiner à
l'intérieur d'un bateau est ce que c est
ce que c'est une ânerie de confiner des
gens dans des cages à lapins où ils
peuvent pas sortir
connaissez la parabole à l'image cages à
lapins style tout le monde on est tout
petit ça pour laisser les petits
c'est pas très grand chez moi d'ailleurs
donc je vois à peu près ce que ça veut
dire
là c'était alors il s'est passé quelque
chose quand même
on a on a vraiment eu
extrêmement
[Musique]
chaud aux fesses
pour tout dire quand
personne n'avait de masques personne ne
prenait de précaution savais pas ce que
c'était et
la prise de conscience a été tardive
avec une épidémie qui doubler le nombre
de cas doublait tous les trois jours
maintenant c'est beaucoup plus lent
doubler tous les trois jours
et les conséquences elle arrive en plus
tôt dix quinze jours après quand une
personne se contaminent nonne et
gravement malade que 15 jours après donc
c'est à dire qu'il ya eu déjà 5
doublement
ans quand on voit les cas graves les
autres sont en train d'arriver derrière
fonction exponentielle c'est la fameuse
fonction exponentielle à ce stade là
on n'est pas passé très loin de ne plus
pouvoir ça c'est un point important il
ya un point de rupture dans le système
de santé c'est au moment où une personne
vient aux urgences avec une urgence
vitale et qu'on peut pas le prendre en
charge parce que il ya plus ni le
personnel ni l'oxygène ni les
respirateurs et les pousse seringue
n'est tout ce qu'on veut donc 6e mais a
manqué quelque chose et à ce moment là
une maladie quelconque devient beaucoup
plus mortels puisque les soins ne sont
pas sont pas donnés on est passé très
très près de sa dans cette première
vague et après à trois jours près ont
été dressés ça enfin trois quatre jours
près
les anglais sont passés un peu de
l'autre côté ils ont peu goûté à ça mais
très vite ils sont fait peur parce que
le les anglais à cette époque là c'était
dit on va laisser faire la nature on va
laisser les gens s'immuniser
les suédois ils sont
ils étaient dans des conditions bien
plus favorable pour maîtriser le truc et
ils ont pas rien fait non plus et puis
ils ont changé d'avis après mais les
anglais ils ont pensé avec une ville
comme londres et c'est que ça passerait
comme ça et c'est pas passé son mirent à
tout bloquer donc danse devant une
urgence comme ça tout bloquer et
effectivement renvoyer les gens chez eux
en assumant qu'il y ait encore de la
contamination interindividuelle chez eux
ça
ça reste explicable parce que la
situation était telle que de toute façon
on pouvait pas
faux n'y avait pas les masques c'était
pas la peine de dire ça servait à rien
mais il n'y avait pas les masques quand
même et il y avait une
propagation de l'épidémie qui était qui
se faisait à vitesse grand v au moins au
pire on m'avait les cas qui contaminait
un peu autour d'eux dans leur domicile
et puis ça s'arrêtait là c'était ça
c'est ce qui s'est passé ça commence
continue à augmenter un peu on peut se
contaminer partout on peut se contaminer
suffit qu'une personne malade sur à côté
d'une personnes non malades si la
personne malade est en dessous de chez
nous au dessus de chez moi non non enfin
ou alors dans la cage d'escalier dans le
dans l'ascenseur gaines de ventilation
de sels de bain qui communique la salle
demain
pour voir le circuit d'air mais je pense
que
c'est pas forcément on récupère pas
forcément l'air de la salle de bal en
dessous si c'est le cas c'est quand même
assez mal conçu 1975 parfait je sais pas
là je peux pas et les ja me santi
lodeiro terme du veau de votre voisin
dans le souffle
n'ont jamais habité ou de lapins
dans le 13ème les tours mais fut moins
démontré lundi pour ça vous voyez
l'odeur de cigarette de votre vos seins
en dessous ça n'est jamais arrivé north
bay à certains endroits oui c'est mais
pas là donc si l'odeur de cigarette de
votre voisin vous le sentez est-ce que
cornavin eaux vives le coronavirus peut
être
non pas en femme on considère que la
transmission plus tôt par gouttelettes
donc le sait pas l'affluence c'est pas
le même modèle que la fumée de cigarette
avec des exceptions etc mais c'est pas
la transmission d'un appartement à
l'autre paraît assez peu probable en
tout cas on ne l'a pas vu non plus en
termes de l'auditeur cette étude y on
aurait vu moi pour le coup j'essaie de
regarder où se passaient les cas et on
on a on n'a pas trouvé de clusters
immeuble sauf des foyers quand il ya
beaucoup de cas la même adresse vous
pouvez dire ça c'est un foyer où c'est
un hôpital ou c mais c'était pas un
immeuble d'habitation
ou c'est l'elysée j'ai pas vu de clameur
à l'elysée à l'époque
quand on voit le noter il a dit dispa
habite à l'elysée le problème quand on
voit notre président de la république
qui détient le feu nucléaire est
contaminée oui
alors hein c'est parce que les services
de renseignement les services de
protection des personnes n'ont pas fait
leur boulot c'est la faute à pas de bol
c'est quoi
je peux pas faire le mal à j'ai été
contaminé moi aussi oui mais bon
d'accord c'est à dire qu'il ya dire il
ya des figures nommé ya des métiers où
on est beaucoup en contact donc faut
assumer qu'on peut on peut l'attraper
moi ça me choque pas je laissais passer
avec le président chinois on n'a pas vu
pendant combien de temps aucune idée je
sais pas au courant de la semaine sera
discuté au président chinois et s'est
planqué pendant un temps non je ne sais
pas mais je vous le dis
est ce que notre chef de l'état y
correctement encadrée pour éviter qu'une
autre feu nucléaire soit mise en danger
par un président malade quand on a un
autre président de l'assemblée nationale
qui a des possibilités d'avoir des
problèmes avec le co vite parce que
surpoids vieux gens ça c'est le sénat
c'est da par mois ce qui vaut autant
pour moi il avait reconnu c'était parce
qu'à cause du de vieux c'est ça c'est ça
à cause de terrains à risque de terrain
merci de douk ça fait est ce que notre
exécutif est suffisamment protégé
est-ce que ça fait pas un peu touristes
chez nous le pays de pasteur que la
femme du président le président soit
malade
non moi ça me choque pas on réellement
ça me choque pas et le plein de gens qui
sont tombés malades
beaucoup plus alors au moment des
municipales ça ça a bien ton fourni
canton comme une idée des masques en
peau de slips dim à notre président de
la république et qui manque de
s'étouffer parce qu'ils respirent et des
substances
nocives pour ces pauvres petits poumons
c'est vous ressentirez épidémiologistes
pas douloureuse spécialisé texte est
d'accord
quand on
voulait couper ah ouais non mais
notre notre copie de 19 aces qu'il sacré
des séquelles à court moyen et long
terme on est en train de dahiya
pourcentage on va dire autour de 10% des
faux 10% sur et tous ceux qui ont été
commis que contaminé son pc en urgence
tous ceux qui sont passés en usage à qui
l'on fait un diagnostic de kobe de lance
d'un brevet pouvait bah oui sinon on ne
peut pas faire pourcentage donc le 10 %
à peu près font des formes un peu avec
une fatigue persistante ce qu'on appelle
les copies de long donc et ça c'est
intéressant c'est à dire ça ça touche
pas que les vieux les jeunes aussi
peuvent faire
des décos vide
voilà un peu prolongé avec la perte du
goût de l'eau droit qui persiste un
certain temps et c'est le reste on sait
pas du tout ce que ça va donner mais on
sait déjà qu'il ya quand même ses formes
peu longue dans le chikungunya on
prenait ça aussi comme maladie assez de
ces original chacun avance
mais c'est vraiment génial jusqu'au
moment où il ya une épidémie à la
réunion et lança personne ne s'est
aperçu qu'il y avait quand même des
formes graves et surtout beaucoup de
douleur de machin de trucs persistantes
ces choses qu'on ne l'imaginait pas
quand on le voyait simplement comme une
maladie de médecine tropicale
chikungunya c'est du swahili je crois
que ça veut dire la maladie de l'homme
courbé met donc c'était de ça disait
déjà ça mais c'est pour nous c'était
juste une espèce de grippe machin comme
ça ta arrivée à la réunion qui a eu
beaucoup de cas en france et on
s'aperçut que des formes comme ça le
conte un virus mais on s'aperçoit
maintenant qu'il ya des formes beaucoup
plus prolongée et c c'est pas des
dizaines qu'il type de séquelles alors
il ya séquelles pulmonaires si longtemps
les gardiens qui ont parlé des séounes
eurologiques donc
démence qui non non ne pas la ramasser
mais donc déjà fatigue perte de goût
perte d'odorat ça peut durer un certain
temps il peut y avoir comme ça certains
de choses et séquelles pulmonaires oui
tout dépend de ce qui s'est passé d'un
point de vu quelqu'un qui a fait cet
orage immunitaire et qui a fait cette
inflammation au niveau des poumons
évidemment que les poumons ne ressortent
pas comme 9 10 ans comment avec une
fibrose léger à la saison de localiser
ça dépend le stade il y en a qu'on
n'arrive pas à récupérer donc il ya des
lésions chez le jeune quel que soit
l'âge des formes très grave des décès
qui interviennent où on a un mal fou à
les ventes il est d'ailleurs un certain
nombre à la pitié salpêtrière
sont ventilés par
circulation extracorporelle c'est le
sens qu on ventile parce que les poumons
ils sont alors ça ça fait des gens qui
restent très très longtemps en
réanimation etc mines souvent par un
décès quand même donc les séquelles
pulmonaires cardiaques oui des
conséquences il ya le problème de la
coagulation
le virus à une activité sur les cellules
à l'intérieur des vaisseaux et donc ça
peut faire des demandes des thromboses
et puis da partir des thromboses et des
embolies donc là encore au début je me
souviens que on n'avait pas associer des
choses il me souhaite que l'un des tout
premiers malades qui est mort on m'a dit
mais non mais il est pas mort du co vide
il a fait une embolie pulmonaire
maintenant c'est que c est donc les
traitements dayan changer quand il ya ce
cette inflammation cet orage immunitaire
on sait qu'il faut donner des
corticoïdes pour la réduire mais aussi
il faut donner des anticoagulants
pour éviter ce risque thromboembolique
comme les bébés une opposition pour
dormir c'est ça chaque année ça change
ah non alors ça c'est encore autre chose
quand j'étais pédiatre c'est vrai que
pendant longtemps disait vous faire
dormir les bébés sur le ventre et il y
avait un quelque chose qu'on appelait la
le
mort subite du nourrisson
les parents qui vont avoir le bébé et il
est mort et en fait quand on a
donné la consigne de faire dormir les
bébés
sur le dos et une réduction très forte
de ces mort subite du nourrisson
et ça ça s'est passé dans les années
dans les années 80 puisque c'est à peu
près je faisais mon interne en pédiatrie
référente internat où ça à marseille
comme sais combien d'années de
spécialisation pédiatre c'est pour
savoir comme j'ai fait d'années d'études
a
fait médecine sept ans ces six ans puis
ensuite la spécialisation ces quatre ans
mais comme j'ai fait pédiatrie
spécialisée dans les maladies
infectieuses j'ai rajouté une année cinq
années et après ça j'ai fait des études
de sciences fait une thèse de sciences
en microbiologie biologie cellulaire je
fais des pcr ont été au point des trucs
de pcr
donc j'ai pris ma dernière carte
d'étudiant en
1996 j'avais donc je me suis pas inscrit
le jour de l'anniversaire de mes trente
six ans donc ce jusqu'à 35 ans donc 17
ans
les tests ces fameux tests pcr les août
et ainsi de suite c'est fiable c'est pas
fiable est ce qu'on peut compter tu pour
faire des diagnostics pour faire des
prévisions d anticipation et des
stratégies ou là c'est beaucoup de
choses
les tests les tests pcr ça c'est fiable
il ya des choses avec les avec les tests
pcr qu'on repère cadets peut-être des
variants
normalement j'essaie de pousser pour que
tout test pcr je pas le seul mais tout
est pcr soit vérifiée question va rien
ça peut être facile on peut utiliser une
pcr pour vérifier si ces invariants
suffit de la configurer de manière
correcte et puis yop par hasard un des
fabricants qui avait une triple pcr dont
deux sont positifs et négatifs si ça le
variant britannique donc ça permettait
aussi de repérer les tests antigénique
ne permettent pas du tout ça et les
tests antigénique il y en ad brand il y
en a des mauvais jixi ce nom ils sont
tous assez les mêmes types de
prélèvements ce problème à zofingue ag
pcr ou test antigénique et maintenant
arrive des tests salivaires oui cela
mais non il est des tests salivaires qui
compterait beaucoup plus facile à
utiliser et au début au début il était
vraiment mauvais et en ajustant les la
manière de procéder le type de deux
tampons à utiliser etc enfin bref et à
la fin on a des tests salivaires qui
maintenant donne de très bons résultats
donc je pense bretonne non c'est pas une
entreprise bretonne qui fait ça mais il
y avait un truc de montpellier mais ça
ça marche pas
mais il ya eu d'autres
là et des expérimentations qui ont été
faites et
je discute assez souvent avec la
personne qui a mené ses études
maintenant elle me dit que les résultats
sont très bons
la stratégie vaccinale
quand on entend notre gouvernement dira
oui vous inquiétez pas au mois de juin
on va augmenter sa vacciner à tour de
bras autour de moi les gars vous
inquiétez pas là on voit que l'institut
pasteur sanofi bon les vaccins ils ont
arrêté on voit que s'il fallait au
rythme où ça va ils vont mettre en
flacon sanofi il faut mettre en flacon
c'est à la fin qu'on lui sait les faire
partir du mois de juillet c'est
peut-être un peu plus compliqué que ça à
faire quand même mais ils vont le faire
mais à partir du haut adige et je sais
pas pourquoi que les iphones acheteurs
arrivent pas à sortir un vaccin c'est
parce qu'on paye pu nous chercheurs est
que nos chercheurs vont chercher pour
les autres puissances
c'est parce que l'institut pasteur il ya
un petit peu de nonchalance un peu du
style je ramène des virus dans une boîte
de flacons que je pose sur mon arrangeur
c'est parce qu'il ya quoi c'est
est-ce que c'est l'on trouve les espaces
et le haut de l'iceberg qui cache la
montagne d'icebergs derrière
il ya certainement un problème est
général mais là dans cette histoire de
deux vaccins
il y avait
deux
pasteurs et sanofi
l'un a tenté quelque chose de très
original
et finalement ça ne marche pas
l'autre étalé sur choses plus classiques
l'utiliser un virus caujolle
atténuer comme vecteur et c'est un moins
bon vecteur que l'adénovirus de
chimpanzés que astrazeneca a utilisé
sachant qu'astrazeneca
n'obtient pas des résultats mirobolants
son sein c'est 70% alors c'est
c'est 70% mais un mélange de 60 2% avec
le protocole comme il l'avait écrit au
départ et puis 90 % avec le protocole
mais une erreur qu'ils ont fait mais sur
un petit effectif on aimerait bien que
ce soit clarifiée
c'est un peu comme une consommation de
voitures serre qui sont sûrement un peu
au départ je ne consomme rien tout va
bien et puis après derrière bon ben
voilà on peut imaginer que y ait les
mêmes le même état d'esprit mais c'est
c'est juste une imagination j'ai pas de
preuves
on va voir si vous avez preuve
l'industrie pharmaceutique les la boue
les big pharmas ce qu'on entend ce
complot ration avec des gens qui
gueulent en disant voilà on a des
certains j'ai oublié j'ai pas parlé de
mes conflit d'altérer ses liens
d'intérêt alors vous n'avez pas je ferai
comme pas ces gens là vous n'avez jamais
touché un peu de pognon
jamais touché un peu de pognon un petit
voyage aux maldives pas de voyage aux
maldives
et laissé sur les cinq dernières années
et un vent louis avant j'ai eu un
congrès p ils s'étaient tous étaient aux
turques et caïques ous les ans un truc
aux états unis mais sont ils à et
floride non texas mais un conte est un
vrai congrès
il est des fous congrès peut imaginer
mais en tout cas c'est pas les vins
maldives et tous à se dire que c'était
c'était en
une vingtaine d'années petit à petit
alors faut bien comprendre que c'est
compliqué personne ne nous paye les
congrès les choses comme ça on n'a pas
l'argent pour ces pays donc on n'y va
pas ou ou
on peut y avoir un laboratoire qui libre
voilà à ce moment là les laboratoires
proposer ce genre de choses et et les
hôpitaux sont reposés sur les
laboratoires pour le faire mais j'ai
progressivement décidé de ne plus avoir
de contact avec les laboratoires
pour a listé avec vous avez fermé la
porte de votre cabinet de votre bureau
ou elissa est ce qu'il ya des gens qui
font la cub en allumant les médecins qui
viennent dé la boule
moi j'ai pas l'impression s'est
énormément
surveiller et même mes collaborateurs
s'ils doivent rencontrer quelqu'un c'est
ils doivent me demander la permission
bon il ya besoin de temps en temps
qu'ils se parlent avec des gens des
laboratoires est pour ça que mes
habitait encore dans une cage à lapins
non
parce que ça me va bien aussi je vous
souhaite pas que c'est une belle chemise
ont à peu près la même non
non mais ça vous fait vous ont donc tous
bible de voir saint l'armée s'est enfin
aucun aucun lien d'intérêt le dernier
repas c'est compliqué sur les autres
explique est ce compliqué il ya c'était
il ya un peu plus de cinq ans et une
réunion de mycologie à aix était à
marseille
j'y suis allé par mes propres moyens
discussion avec les hématologues
maladies infectieuses se représenter la
bonne micro logist important d'être là
et d'avoir quelques trucs à grignoter
et sur le truc de transparence et avait
marqué que ben voilà j'avais on m'avait
payé un repas repas 63 euros j'ai du mal
à comprendre je me suis aperçu qu'on ne
leur pas mais c'est c'est
eh puis deux puis je fais même attention
à ça je ne veux pas
faire ce genre de choses mais par
exemple il ya deux ans de ça on m'a
proposé d'aller sur une séance
d'enseignement de choses comme ça avec
les collectes organisées par un labo
gilead
gdim je veux bien aller et vous ne me
nourris sais pas
vous ne m'inscris vais pas je viens
j'assiste je fais ce que vous voulez
mais je ne veux pas avoir un truc a
signé un truc eh bien ça n'a pas été
possible
et je ne suis pas allé parce qu'il
fallait que je passe en contre avec eux
pour aller
parler d'un sujet que je connaissais
très bien que l'utilisation de
l'intelligence artificielle on
diagnostique médical je ne pouvais pas
le faire et donc j'ai su parler je peux
me permettre ça moi j'ai pas besoin pour
ma carrière d'aller dans ces trucs là et
je suis invité par les organisateurs des
congrès les sociétés savantes si j'ai
suffisamment d'occasions d'aller voir
les collègues mais quelqu'un de jeune et
beaucoup plus en difficulté donc
attention quand même de limiter par
contre c'est pas la peine de doubler son
salaire ou des choses comme ça aussi
c'est encore hélas est de même pas du
salaire dont je parle voilà un chef de
service de la plage les
mois je suis au top
comment s'est dit dit raul qui disait
qu'il a le truc là donc c'est le grade
le plus haut c'est professeur des
universités classe exceptionnelle
deuxième échelon donc ça plus et
l'hôpital paix comme chef de service
avait conseillé noté maximum et tout ça
ça fait
sept mille et quelques 7500 puisque
voilà net après après impôts par mois
donc c'est un bon salaire
quand vous lis certains médecins qu on
appelle ça des médecins de plateaux télé
parce que j'y vais aussi ouais mais vous
avez sept mille vols par mois et ne
touchent des sommes à peu près
mirobolante ça vous fait quoi de les
entendre de les voir plus sur les
plateaux télé que dans les services mon
faux
chacun vit sa vie et chacun son bonheur
donc ses promesses passent aussi une
force qui veulent s'ils veulent aller
plus à la télé
après en tant que malade ça
m'emmerderait de payer très cher médecin
pendant pendant 10 minutes 20 minutes
quelques jeux face à certaines
spécialités où ça ça dégage et c'est
bon c'est donc de ce côté-là ça
m'embêterait mais sinon il faut vivre
leur vie je suis pas jaloux d'eux quand
on entend dire big pharma
mesure le labo x qui a fait 1 le vaccin
y a déjà été condamné à tant de
milliards d'euros parce qu il a fraudé
tel type d'études ihs s'arranger avec
les résultats et des principes de
corruption
[Musique]
est-ce que ça participe au fait que le
vaccin va être moins bien reçue c'est à
dire que ceux qui sont déjà fait taper
la main dans le pot de confiture
de vienne on va dire les souvent les
gens n'y croient plus est ce que vous
comprenez les gens qui ont des doutes
sur les labos qui ont déjà été pris la
main dans le pot de confiture
moi je pense qu'il ne devrait même pas
avoir de doute sur un certain nombre de
la bo qui essaient de se faire du pognon
lesquels
qu'il ait had c'est pas trop leur ya pas
de doute que la finalité c'est de faire
de l'argent quand il prit propose des
traitements de l'hépatite c des prix qui
était vraiment élevé il ya de quoi ne
pas être très très heureux donc il n'y a
pas de doute là dessus que
la santé ça permet d'avoir de l'argent
alors ensuite il ya des choses je sais
que astrazeneca par exemple pour
travailler avec ces avec oxford
la condition c'est qu'il fasse ça à prix
coûtant j'avais pour ça qu'on parle d'un
vaccin beaucoup moins cher et c'est
modern a par contre c'est l'histoire de
faire de l'argent aussi
à nous de choisir dans quel dans quel
monde on veut vivre mais ça ne remet pas
forcément en cause
la qualité du produit à la fin pour le
coup
ces vaccins arn qui sont très très
innovant donc
on est vraiment impressionné par leur
efficacité
vous avez été vaccinés avec lequel vous
celui-là le swing de phison deuxième
injection c'est quand ça c'est mardi
prochain c'est devait tracer une
deuxième injection un peu yoyo devait la
faire trois semaines après multiplie les
petites 12 en rallongeant le nom wii
comme il ya peu de vaccins on est en
pénurie l'idée a été enfin les anglais
l'ont fait pas forcément chaud comme les
anglais l'ont fait ils ont écarté le
truc comme ça y est on à la protection
de la première dose mais cette
protection manifestement pour ce type de
vaccin et pacy
pas la panacée c'est pas la panacée il
faut faire les deux doses la preuve
la protection de
l'immunisation que avec ça vous donne
c'est combien de temps ses trois mois
cinq mois 6 mois disant ça dure quand
même temps pour pouvoir répondre il faut
vacciner des gens aient regardé pendant
trois mois cinq mois 6 mois dix ans on a
regardé pendant trois mois après il faut
plus de temps mais sur le vaccin et
récents sur les effets secondaires c'est
la même chose
sur les effets secondaires et les effets
secondaires immédiat la réaction locale
et puis ce qu'on appelle l'anaphylaxie
voilà le donc l'anaphylaxie on peut la
repérer on peut on sait que c'est à peu
près 1 sur 100 milles
ça se il faut prendre des précautions
c'est pour ça que l'on lâche pas les
gens comme ça si si ça se fait en milieu
médical ça ne pose aucun problème ça ccc
repris il ya l'adrénaline enfin il ya
des choses qui peuvent être faites
et puis ça passe c'est juste une
réaction allergique très passagère
mais il faut la traiter immédiatement
les effets tardifs si tant est qu'il y
ait des effets tardifs on ne peut pas
les connaître
là en même temps il vaut mieux enfin un
des effets tardifs des vaccins
je crois qu'il faut oublier cette
histoire de syndrome de guillain barré
autres sclérose en plaques provoquée par
les vaccins ça n'a jamais été démontrée
et où des cas parce que sont pas des
maladies rarissime pour qu'il ya des
coïncidences mais en terme de deux
nombres et ya pas une
sur risque ou quelque chose lié à la
vaccination
gd des vaccins par exemple dans des pays
sous développés où les gens mangent du
riz où les gens mangent rien
à vacciner des gens sains d'une façon
conséquente et on s'est retrouvé avec
des cas de séquelles importantes vous
avez jamais vu ça il y avait le
traitement de la bilharziose qui avait
entraîné entraîner des problèmes
d'hépatite c était un traitement
intraveineux
il y avait des défauts aussi il ya eu
des défauts de stérilisation du matériel
d'injection
d'ailleurs c'était ça aussi pour donc il
ya eu des choses comme ça
là maintenant au matériel à usage unique
c'est quand même pas tout à fait la même
chose mais bien sûr qu'il ya eu des
histoires comme ça oui
j'aurais pas les retrouver tout c'est un
peu dans les livres d'histoire de de la
médecine on sait qu'il ya eu des trucs
comme ça on sait que bon voilà les
certain moment le les médecins
particulier dans le les médecins
coloniaux ont eu des monnaies des
campagnes qui était pas forcément
dénué de risques pour les pour les
patients
là on n'est pas en mode médecin
coloniale avec une économie exempt est
ce que le vaccin c'est pas un vaccin
politique c'est à dire
on fait ça à la va comme je te pousse
parce que on veut surtout pas avoir des
hôpitaux ou train surchargé avec des
gens qu'on est obligé de tri dans la rue
avec des gens qui commencent à cannes et
sur les parkings ou à canet chez eux
donc politiquement parlant on ne pourra
pas l'assumer parce que faire des images
de journalistes qui file est un peu un
peu comme les colis alimentaires chez
les étudiants en ce moment où il ya des
gens qui font la queue y y et puis tous
les dix mètres il y en a qui tombe parce
que bon bah il n'était pas très bien
donc ça politiquement parlant on peut
pas se permettre donc est ce que les
politiques du monde occidental ont
poussé est repoussé et repoussé pour
contrefaçon ou vacciner parce que c'est
un vaccin politique non
c'est pas les politiques qui poussent
c'est nous qui pousse on
compose parce que il ya
une maladie alors à la fois
individuellement n'importe quelle
personne peut tomber malade et et faire
une forme grave y compris il ya des
formes graves chez les enfants puis sans
être des formes graves et à ses formes
chroniques dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure
et la deuxième chose
c'est qu'effectivement on est quand même
dans une situation tout à fait
particulière mais quand même à 75 mille
morts en france
ça fait quand même 75 mille morts de
qu'on fait une petite grippette oui pour
une grippe honnête c'est énorme
de confinement des les bars qui sont
fermés depuis le mois de septembre les
restaurants les cinémas en fin et tout
et tout et en l'air etc d'un point de
vue économique mais d'un point de vue
sanitaire il ya toujours du retard dans
la prise en charge des autres patients
ma part à râpez tout le retard de l'aco
vide quand même eu des des personnes qui
ont des cancers qui ont été
diagnostiqués plus tard ça a été montré
donc il ya quand même une des
conséquences qui sont fortes et encore
parce qu'elles sont moins fortes que
lors pu être si on avait laissé
l'épidémie se développe et maintenant on
comprend qu'on aurait vraiment eu des
centaines de milliers de morts que les
modélisateurs nous disait si on n'avait
pas eu tous et toutes ces affaires de
confinement et c'est donc
maintenant
un travail a été fait d'excellentes
qualités de sur les vaccins en tout cas
sur ces deux vaccins et rennes
quand des résultats excellents l'astra
zeneca on en a parlé c'est depuis les
autres on attend les résultats
n'ont voulu utiliser ça c'est
aucun doute sur le lin théret
individuel en fait de tout le monde ou à
la limite c'est vrai qu'une personne
jeune qui a déjà fait la coved bon ça va
faire une fois il y en a qui l'ont fait
plusieurs fois mais c'est quand même
assez rare qui à l'espacement entre les
deux
c'est une perte un espacement ainsi ses
membres a aussi moins simple ruse et une
contamination ou effet une résurgence
deuxième contamination avec des souches
différentes
réponses c'est à dire ils ont testé la
la souche ils auront fait les génotypes
ils ont vu qu'elle était différente donc
il ya un certain nombre de cas prouvé
comme ça maintenant alors
maintenant dans ce qu'on a ici
en france ça va
reste ce qui se passe à manaus
une ville brésilienne au milieu de
l'amazonie pouvant amazonas qui
avait un peu laissé faire la première
vague ç'avait été assez assez meurtrier
alors la population est relativement
jeune donc le nombre de morts au brésil
et pas forcément beaucoup plus fort il
est à peu près similaire au nombre de
morts par million d'habitants en france
mais eux ils sont plus jeunes donc ça
représente quand même beaucoup de morts
ce c'est la pyramide des âges la
population influe énormément et donc
manaus a été considérée il ya même eu un
article scientifique qui a mesuré le
l'immunisation de la population ils ont
considéré qu' on était autour du muniesa
sion autour de plus de 70% de la
population qui était immunisé et la
manaus subit à nouveau une deuxième
vague d'une violence terrible
là on peut penser que une nouvelle
souche c'est là quand même c'est les
japonais qui ont isolé cette nouvelle
souche de personnes qui venaient de
manos donc une nouvelle souche est là et
peut-être que c'est très logiquement il
doit y avoir pas mal de personnes qui
ont été touchées deux fois une fois par
l'ancienne île fois par la nouvelle
souche on manque de données s'est pas
l'endroit où il ya le plus d'équipés
active qui nous fournissent des données
scientifiques
revenons
vous avez signé combien de certificat de
décès donc je fais l'épidémiologie je
suis content si vous voulez mais c'est
tout ne s'est même pas moi qui compte
vous désignez comme un c'est pas moi qui
ai signé certificat de décès la
déontologie médicale
2 le code d'éthique de la médecine bon
j'ai pas besoin de vous faire réciter le
serment d'hippocrate parce que quand on
reçoit un gérant un journaliste ou du
fait à peu près à réciter la charte de
munich mais on va pas faire ça avec un
toubib parce que on vous sent plus je
sais que je suis pas du genre à
apprendre les versets les uns après les
autres
par contre l'idée générale oui je peux
vous expliquer c'est ça l'idée générale
l'idée générale du serment d'hippocrate
c'est que on fait pas payer plus que son
voeu on se comporte on se comporte bien
avec les les patients en quelque sorte
on ne profite pas de sa marge rouge
aucune et de aucune
discrimination en fonction de la
religion etc ont fait pas payer plus que
ce qu ont quelque chose de correct on
est ce qu'on va voir donc voilà c'est un
de ces des règles de comportement
vis-à-vis du patient quand ne pour qu'on
ne profite pas de l'avantagé que nous
donne le le savoir du médecin auquel
sont fixes à
oui je le respecte en tout cas moi oui
mais quand il ya certains dentistes qui
regardent les gars qu'on a c'est mieux
un peu de travers du genre où il a lui
va me coûter du pognon je vais le faire
passer 3 3 heures plus tard où je vais
pas le prendre je veux dire je suis
occupé des choses comme ça se fait
toujours ce n'est pas faute bordeaux
dentiste en question il ya toujours une
médecine à trois vitesses en france
trois vitesses je sais pas elle à la
médecine vous arriver aux urgences vous
n'y connaissez rien vous avez vous
arrivez à l'hôpital américain ça va plus
vite et vous êtes fils de médecin ou
médecin vous même à la ccl casino royale
ça existe toujours ça en france
probablement oui même
il vaut mieux si par hasard si j'étais
fils de gastro entérologue par exemple
sur le signal de maxillo faciale ou de
matteo faciale chirurgie maxillo faciale
oui voilà sur le signalerait à l'arrivée
vous mieux faciliter les choses
arriver une anecdote c'était dans
l'hérault je fais un lumbago très sévère
je vais à l'hôpital je dis rien
et puis vraiment votre tête c'était mal
barré c'est ça non j'avais j'avais même
pas la barbe ni rien donc c'est
finalement jeudi à mon épouse de monter
dans les étages il essaie de trouver en
interne voilà
elle monte dans les étages elle trouve l
antenne interne dit mon nom
mais je le connais et non je passais pas
la télé à l'époque j'avais en fait il
avait été mon logisticiens quand j'ai
fait une mission
honduras ce derrière une catastrophe non
qui on s'est retrouvé là est évidemment
là j'ai pu attendre
donc oui c'est mais quand on a passé
quatre heures aux urgences avec vraiment
très mal et qu'on voit que la personne
qui vient et c'est vrai que c'est c'est
pénible et on a beau vouloir être
égalitaire on finit par se dire et quand
imaginez vous vous êtes spécialisé dans
la chirurgie de la main et vous allez en
u19 tout comme vous êtes un bon médecin
vous ne dites pas que votre fils est
votre fils et que vous est spécialisé
dans la main ouais parce que vous êtes
lent avec votre fille si ces coupes eu
la main tout seul vous allez à l'hôpital
public le toubib vous regardez vous dire
mon bas mot pour me chanter rien du tout
on va mettre un coup de pub shit
aurez vous ressortez de l'hôpital par
exemple un hôpital près d'antibes ou
d'aunis ouais et que et que vous
ressortez votre fils il vous appelle
vous êtes quand même chirurgien de la
main vous avez créés soit et cela il
vous a payé à papa quand même là on a
déconné et là vous appelez l'hôpital
américain et dans les cinq minutes il se
fait opérer il avoue trouver atteint
tendineuse la totale vous faites quoi le
en main vous appelez le chef de service
de l'hosto vous a plu le directeur de
l'hôpital vous fait raser le service
vous faites quoi
j'avais fait ça m'est arrivé des trucs
comme ça et j'ai rien fait
trop gentil vous en faire autre chose
jal doit casser il a été mal réparé
c'était qui veulent changer c'est ce
aller à mazamet bon genre peut-être pas
dû aller à mazamet et là il l'a pas
remis droit au vous arranger ça pas si
vous voulez
j'ai cassé un passage comme ils
effraient pas piloter la chasse c'est
pas grave voilà et revenons revenons la
médecine à trois vitesses là les lits ou
n'en a créés depuis la première vague
s'est dotée on s'est doté de stocks on
s'est doté de c'est un faux problème il
n'y a pas assez de lits mais quand on
parle le lit c'est qu'il n'y a pas assez
de personnel
donc est-ce qu'on peut créer du
personnel hospitalier en six mois non
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut corriger
ça va prendre beaucoup de temps
il faudrait corriger à hauteur de
combien 5 10 15 20 % récupérer les 110
mille lits dont plus personne qui avait
en fait quand
c'était absolument plus mon métier là je
peux je peux dire qu'il n'y a pas assez
de monde je peux pas le chiffrer
et en plus on pandémie évidemment de
toute façon quand un moment dit il faut
deux fois plus de places en réa là ça
devient vraiment très compliqué à créer
on peut peut-être pas doubler le nombre
de médecins d'infirmiers et c'est dans
tous les mets très clairement en manque
de monde le l'hôpital a trop diminuée
trop été rétrécie il faut maintenant
développer mais ça se fait pas en six
mois est ce qu'il ya une pénurie de
polypropylène
oui le polypropylène à une pénurie pour
li propylène c'est un composant en fait
de deux matières plastiques c'est qui
quêtent certaines résistent de propriété
parce que c'est que si j'ai bien compris
c'est ce qu'on met dans les choses qu'on
va centrifuge et au cou ou les icônes de
micro pipe est une chose comme ça
oui à cette pénurie alors il essaie
aussi je pense dans la composition des
masques en tout cas
on a reçu il ya une dizaine de jours
depuis une dizaine de jours on reçoit
des des consignes comme quoi faut
regarder ce qu'on a en stock faut
commencer à faire attention à ce qu'on
utilise et c'est donc j'ai essayé de
signaler le problème sachant que après
c'est un peu compliqué qu'est ce que ça
veut dire c'est qu'en fait si on se
retrouve plus que des pipettes des
petits cônes ou des choses comme ça
c'est qu'on peut pu tester bas à la fin
où ils sont c'est comme une version
faire baisser les cours buts en moins de
deux ans en bunkers mais est ce que est
ce qu'on va en arriver là j'en sais rien
moi je suis pas je suis pas le plus doué
pour faire le diagnostic
donc j'ai essayé de simplement de
d'alerté là dessus donc l'utilité dans
l'injection en face alerter ou
pratiquement
auprès des députés
par une lettre par une question
comme les culs âgées questions au
gouvernement voilà donc ce mardi dernier
et même auprès du premier ministre
parce que j'avais l'occasion
mais
je relancerai je sais pas encore mais
pas ce soir ils vont bien l'entendre on
est bien suivi de près par le
gouvernement
donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'on se retrouve avec un variant qui
peut être plus invasif en plus à un toit
un taux de contagion plus intéressant
sur le produit preuve pauvre
polypropylène
propylène voilà le problème donc c'est
qu'on nous demande de faire de faire
attention dans une discussion qu'on a
eue il ya quelques jours au niveau 2 du
département médicaux universitaires de
des laboratoires en fait 2 ap hp
sorbonne universités on se pose des
questions
on n'arrive plus à commander ça devient
difficile les fournisseurs sont en
rupture de stock manifestement c'est un
problème général c'est un problème
mondial et ça vient autour des matières
premières ça vient au tour de de la
surconsommation de ce type de matière
après c'est pas trop mon métier d'aller
plus loin mais il me semble est quand
même important que on sache et c'est
vrai qu'il m'est arrivé de vivre des
situations où je croyais que tout était
sous contrôle etc et des fois ça ne
l'est pas donc c'est pour ça que j'ai
préféré quand même le signaler
mais ça se trouve c'est gérer si ça se
trouve c'est nous on a avant de vous
recevoir on applique quelques copains
dans les hôpitaux est capable de se
renseigner d'une façon différente ouais
au niveau de leurs stocks qui c'était à
peu près deux semaines 12 tonnes que ces
cinq minimes oui mais c'est pas beaucoup
de semaines
il son logisticien ou s'ils sont les
futurologues
horrible parce qu'on travaille en flux
tendu donc il ya beaucoup moins de stock
il ya des stocks stratégiques dans cette
île comme les masques
donc il vaut mieux quand même le
signaler et c'est vrai que ça veut dire
quoi concrètement pour nos auditeurs qui
nous écoutent cia piper de ça veut dire
quoi battisti ça veut dire
qu'actuellement il ya encore des
pipettes d'accord rien est encore fait
tout ce qu'il faut mais après
effectivement toute la biologie repose
sur le fait de prendre des petites
quantités très très mesuré d'un liquide
dans le sérum n'importe quoi mis dans un
dans un des flacons sait où des petits
tubes on appelle ça les petits bendorf
les flacons et c est donc c'est des
choses qu'on mesure tous ces petits
trucs en plastique ces consommables de
plastique sont jetés à chaque fois parce
que c'est du matériel stérile et c'est
ce ces consommables de plastique ça
bouge ses consommables de plastique sont
le dis souvent vous devez en riz sont
indispensables pour faire
par exemple des pcr du séquençage de la
sérologie et plein d'autres choses
donc ça veut dire si on se prend un
nouveau variant plus invasif plus
corrosif plus facilement transmissible
l'autre on peut vraiment lent ne laisser
ni un peu partout et qu'on a plus de
matériel non mais on n'a pas besoin
d'avoir de nouveaux mariés variant pour
qu'on ait un problème si on a plus de
matériel
la biologie elle sert à tout la médecine
donc il faut il faut faire quelque chose
c'est beaucoup plus grave que nous
devrions ce terrain là on peut plus
testé ma vie ici un cancer a pas de
cancer on peut plus prendre vos testud
pour l'instant on n'a pas cette pénurie
simplement on nous alertent que les
fournisseurs sont pas capables de nous
fournir dans les délais
j'aimerais bien savoir où on en est de
cette situation effectivement être
certain que le truc est géré ce que je
ne sais pas parce que évidemment
c'est pas juste au moment où on pose la
question il faut pas s'attendre que on
met les rats réponse immédiatement c'est
n'est pas nos interlocuteurs sont sont
pas censés tout connaître tous les trucs
mais je suppose qu'ils sont en train de
regarder et que dans les jours qui
viennent nous aurons des messages nous
disons bien sûr c'est géré
vaut mieux demander vos yeux oui c'est
ça c'est votre rôle de médecin aussi
d'assurer la santé de vos passions futur
c'est pour ça que vous demandez c'est ça
c'est parce qu'il est arrivé que des
choses que je pensais être en stocks
n'étaient pas en stock les masques
il ya eu un papier du monde qui disait
que avant l'appel à la première vague on
était déjà en short sur les
antibiotiques les antibio et sur
d'autres trucs short genre tu es ce que
vous avez l'impression que la médecine
en france est devenue le parent pauvre
la variante ajustable de nos politiciens
très clairement on est quand même dans
une politique de flux tendu il n'y a pas
de stock et ça c'est des choses qui
rendent le travail extrêmement pénible
après
il ya beaucoup de parents pauvres la
médecine n'est pas le seul
mais c'est la manière de gérer
l'avenir du jury
c'est pas de stock mais c'est peu parlé
à bâtons rompus et oui la manière de
gérer est ce que vous n'avez pas
l'impression d'avoir payé des impôts
pendant des décennies et se retrouver
qu'un système de santé qui est exempt
avec pinpin épi pou qui faisait mou
c'est parce qu'il était directeur de
machin de bidules et puis quand ils
arrivent avec l'événement x et exotique
extérieurs peints pipi prison ils ont
disparu après qui sait non mais pour
éviter de donner des noms oui un pipe ou
avec leurs salaires mirobolants et leurs
titres très prestigieux sur leur carte
de visite pinpin épi pou qui ont été
sélectionnés par un système éducatif qui
donnent eux que des pantins et des
pipots
en fait ils servent à rien ces gens là
il continue de gérer une crise qui n'ont
pas su gérer une première fois moi vous
n'êtes pas chef d'entreprise et un chef
d'entreprise qui se retrouve avec un
pipi pour une fois pain pipe ou deux
fois il n'y a pas d'atteinte un épi pou
trois fois on
est ce qu'on est bien gérée en france
on a peut-être un problème avec la haute
administration
mais
comment dire
parce que déjà se sont pas des chefs
d'entreprise ils sont des gens qui ont
appris à administrer
donc ils font d'énormes et 10 vous devez
faire comme si vous devez faire comme ça
le jour où ils doivent faire c'est c'est
pas leur métier donc la ja il ya un
problème et puis y'a le le problème
aussi c'est au sort un de trucs mais le
problème aussi de du parapluie
quand on fait une belle carrière comme
ça on a peut-être intérêt à pas prendre
de risque
bakouba dans bruit c'est ça oui l'un
plus l'autre fait que sur un
fonctionnement routinier c'est quelque
chose que simplement
exaspérant c'est énervant tout ça et on
on and on peut avoir des difficultés sur
une période de crise là on est cerné sur
menace manquer plus adapté
il faut d
je pense
j'ai participé à beaucoup de gestion de
crise et ne fonctionnait pas de la même
manière quand on ça m'est arrivé par
exemple d'aller à goma c'est plein de
coeur de l'afrique il ya un volcan le
volcan avait fait une éruption une
partie de la ville était sous là sous la
lave les gens étaient partis très peu de
mordant dans ce truc là et surtout de
mort quand ils ont voulu prendre de
l'essence dans une station d'essence a
explosé mais les sinon les gens étaient
partis puis reviennent beaucoup de
personnes n'ont plus la maison etc et
je suis arrivé avec le retour des gens
donc à peu près soixante douze heures
par rapport à la catastrophe et là où on
doit doit remettre en place un certain
nombre de choses et pour moi ça a été de
voir où en était le système de santé
comment on organisait les choses pour
que rapidement l'elysée un accès aux
soins etc et ça on le fait en l'espace
de 2 3 jours s'organise et on passe et
ça ça va à toute vitesse comment on fait
on se met tous autour d'une table avec
des gens qui sont relativement aguerri
il ya les bailleurs de fonds qui sont là
qui met l'argent l'union européenne en
particulier usa il dit aussi et on y va
on démarre on embauche les gens pour le
faire on se conforme et c'est ce type de
de fonctionnement n'est pas celui qu'on
a actuellement dans la gestion de la
crise on a des personnes qui sont
chargées de de faire leur boulot
habituellement et donc qu'ils continuent
à faire leur boulot et qui continue à
raisonner mais si je fais ça je risque
de d'avoir un problème est donc
toujours vérifier si les choses peuvent
se faire de telle ou telle manière etc
bref ça prend un temps fou et on n'est
pas du tout efficace
donc là il ya un problème comme ça si on
veut aborder ça c'est mais c'est pas le
moment il faudra parler quand même l'on
parle de ça mais on est
aujourd'hui on revient vers une vague il
faut peut-être aussi quand même signalé
çà
aujourd'hui
on reviendra sur le conseil de guerre
après je compte sur vous pour me
rappeler de guerre ouais
oui nous sommes en guerre vous n'êtes
pas au courant
des miss est déjà pire
on se on est selon vous quand montréal à
la veille
d'une nouvelle vague oui
dans quelle ampleur dans quelles
proportions
est ce qu'on est préparé à ce que le
conseil de guerre de pinpin épi pou va
faire servir à quelque chose qu'est-ce
qu'on fait un pari plus pour ne les
connais pas mais où est-ce qu'on en est
on en est déjà avec beaucoup de gens
hospitalisés actuellement
27 mille corps dans les cliniques
privées en ce moment va
certainement y avoir quelques places
atteler flanc droit mais je lui ai donné
une comparaison 27000 personnes
hospitalisées pour l'aco vide mois de
mars le pic a été à 32000
en octobre 33 mieux donc on est on est
très haut
en réa c'est moins marquant c'est un peu
plus bas le à peu près 3100 mars ont été
montées autour de 7000 donc et octobre
c'est un peu intermédiaire mais quand
même on est aussi donc on part pas d'une
situation où les hôpitaux sont là
tranquille on vient venez on va pouvoir
vous occupez ils sont déjà pleins sont
plaints parce qu'il ya les autres
malades aussi un le bien de lits de vous
deux vous le savez financer santé
publique france vous pouvez on peut les
retrouver facilement
donc moi je les regarde tous les jours
et donc qu'on a on a ce
ce contexte là ensuite on a beaucoup de
nouveaux cas tous les jours en fait si
on met déjà en augmentation
derrière ça se passe qui est un
changement de souche on avait notre
souche qui n'était pas si pépère que ça
m'inquiétait qu'on arrivait à peu près à
maîtriser pas totalement puisque c'est
le truc continuer à augmenter malgré
quand même
toutes les mesures prises important
parce que couvre feu etc et on va avoir
donc le premier changement c'est que là
la courbe va s'infléchir puisque le
temps de doublement de l'épidémie va se
raccourcir puisque là arrivent à la
place de la souche actuelle une souche
plus contagieuse 60% plus contagieuse
c'est considérable donc premier temps un
fléchissement de la courbe qui est pour
maintenant c'est le le remplacement est
en cours ne peut être on est au-dessus
de 10% mais peut-être entre 15 et 20% ça
c'est des mesures qui sont un petit peu
plus compliqué à avoir mais on est on
est un taux qui est quand même élevé et
surtout ça va très très vite une fois
que c'est arrivé à ces niveaux là ça va
très très vite pour être majoritaire une
histoire de quelques semaines pendant
ces quelques semaines on avait affaire à
une souche qui avait une certaine
contagiosité on va avoir à faire une
autre souche qui est 60% plus
contagieuse ça réduit le le temps
doublement où ça augmente le taux de
reproduction de l'épidémie dont une
reproduction de l'épidémie qui augmente
plus de cas on voit plus de kloster on
voit plus de choses comme ça on voit
plus de cas aussi dans les hôpitaux plus
de personnel qui est touché par par ces
clusters la vaccination va peut-être
aidé pour ça mais pour l'instant il ya
quand même beaucoup de clusters s'il ya
plus de cas dans quelques temps huit dix
jours après il y aura plus de cas graves
ils vont donc il va y avoir plus de
personnes aux urgences plus de personnes
hospitalisées
plus de personnes en réanimation mais ça
c'est le flux entrants les sorties se
font pas immédiatement et donc il va y
avoir encore accumulation donc le mois
de février ce sera le mois du
remplacement de la souche et durant
durant le mois de février le truc va
monte monte monte et très vite on va se
retrouver avec une vague d'intensité
oui plus fort que les précédentes
la seule chose qui va permettre de
d'arrondir le sommet de la vague c'est
l'immunisation ou alors des mesures
extrêmement fortes alors l'immunisation
on voit ce qui se passe dans les
endroits où le truc a dérapé elle arrive
très tardivement et encore maintenant
sont même pas eu mais le il ya vraiment
un problème donc on est obligé de
freiner et de recommencer des choses qui
sont effectivement
pas du tout agréable c'est un plus en
plus c'est n'importe quoi il faudrait
mieux isoler chaque personne
individuellement on peut parler de ce
qui ce qui peut se faire mais dans un
premier temps ça c'est confinement les
choses comme ça un confinement mi-figue
mi-raisin hybrides ou
un pipeau c'est quoi un confit non moi
je devrais plutôt aux figues de barbarie
sco jean van hamme il n'y avait pas une
épine partoune a enfin un vrai
confinement un pare d'éléments de
langage pondu par un cabinet de conseils
qu'on paye mais c'est ça
je serai là péter pas un élément de
langage tendu par un cabinet de conseils
qu'on paye blindes owens pas de ça dont
on parle effectivement c'est de limiter
les interactions entre les gens ferme
rihanna et ça veut dire télétravail à
fond moins de monde dans les transports
en commun
fermeture des lycées des collèges et des
écoles les écoles
bad façon de femmes tout allait enfin
c'est les écoles ça peut être un
ça peut être un point et discuter parce
que les enfants petits sont quand même
moins c'est pas d'issue nominaux
c'est plus les adolescents et on sait ce
qu'on fait on les vacances
commencent les vacances un peu plus tôt
puis on verra bien la fin des vacances
si si vraiment la situation est
confortable ou si on est toujours dans
une situation extrêmement si le truc
s'est très fortement dégradé ben on
prolonge les vacances
si on ne peut pas parler de fermeture
des salles éléments de langage le
professeur how we dans une vidéo il n'y
a pas trois jours ou un jour dit le
confinement ça sert à rien mondialement
parlons ça a été prouvé que ça servait à
rien d'ailleurs le professeur you do je
me rappelle plus comment il s'appelle
dit que ça ne sert à rien qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez lui répondre
le professeur j'ai travaillé avec lui
une bonne expérience
c'est une expérience intéressante
je rappellerai simplement que j'irais
pas prendre conseil auprès de lui sur la
gestion de l'épidémie parce que c'est
aussi lui qui a expliqué qu aurait pas
de deuxième vague d'ailleurs devait pas
y en avoir deux premières
que
les accidents de trottinettes et tout le
sketch delà de la chloroquine qui n'a
pas réglé le problème en tout cas on
voit bien que
on est tous dans en difficulté compris à
marseille sont en difficulté donc j'irai
pas voilà ces jeux je fais pas confiance
il peut dire des choses intéressantes
mais je ne vais pas mettre ma main à
couper que ce qu'il dit est est exact je
suis pas vraiment le confinement c'est
pas ça que je voulais moi c'est pas ce
pas ce genre de choses c'est pas ça qui
a permis au pays de s'en sortir le mieux
ce qui a fait la différence entre les
pays qui s'en sortent et ceux qui s'en
sortent pas c'est le contact tracking
ça ça fait vraiment la différence et ça
fait toujours la différence et des pays
qui font mieux ça que d'autres alors on
va dire c'est la culture etc mais très
clairement là il ya quelque chose qui
peut être fait mais quand on se retrouve
face à une situation où on risque
d'avoir le cet engorgement on va l'avoir
notre façon mais à un niveau tel que
les gens ne pourront plus se faire
soigner correctement c'est le professeur
problème là qui se passe alors il faut à
tout prix freiner le dernier ou outils
pour freiner c'est celui là
parlons de contact rakeen
le contactera king il aurait pu
il ya un moment où il fallait le faire
c'était au mois de mai avant avant mars
on n'était pas prêts
mais mais quand on des confine là il
fallait y aller le nombre de cas diminue
et diminuer diminué fallait se donner
les moyens de les détecter et autour de
ces cas d'organiser des visites à
domicile expliquer aux gens comment
faire leur fournir masque matériel faire
les courses il le faut leur proposer des
chambres à l'hôtel dans le dans la
mesure où le nombre de cas étaient
faibles on pouvait prendre là
on pouvait prendre la main sur
l'épidémie didier raoul cas a dit à ce
moment là aussi qu'il fallait fermer les
frontières c'est exact à partir du
moment où la terrine fermer les
frontières c'est quand on n'a pas
beaucoup de cas qu'il y en a beaucoup à
l'extérieur à ce moment remet un terrain
fermé
fermer quand on a plein de câlins
intérieur ça change pas grand chose
mais à l'extérieur ils en ont plein
aussi donc ça ça n'a plus sanaa plus il
ya quelque chose sur les mouvements des
variants mais quand les variantes sont
déjà installés sanaa
ça n'a pas grand chose ça n'apporte pas
grand chose mais par contre mois de
juillet quand il y avait pratiquement
pas de cas et que des cas arrivé de
l'extérieur où il a on aurait dû un
maître le le paquet pour arriver à 0 k à
l'intérieur il y restait et éviter que
les gens viennent alors fermer les
frontières ou vous faire une quarantaine
et j'en arrive pendant 14 jours il reste
comme le l'équipe de la ms qu'est rester
en quarantaine pendant quinze jours en
chine après pipe ou
wave
n'a pas pu bidou
peut-être dans en tout cas ça c'était le
moment de le faire mais le contact
tracking ça fait ça se fait avec des
gens sur le terrain le fait de le faire
uniquement par téléphone est beaucoup
moins efficace donc on est passé à côté
maintenant on peut plus on peut plus
revenir mais il ya quelque chose à faire
est quelque chose à faire ce qu'on
arrive dans une période intense et quand
même pas mal de gens qui qui qui vont
peut-être regarder cette cette vidéo
est une chose à faire c'est bien
comprendre et bien expliqué
quand une personne est positive le déjà
quand elle a des signes il faut bon il
faut se il faut se tester des signes
c'est un petit caca midi face à sion der
mis
les bouchées un peu de fièvre mal à la
tête très fatigué bon maintenant les
choses sont faites et on qui gratte un
peu nous des manifestations
dermatologiques pas tellement non pense
plutôt à se faire aux airelles
camou il y en a qui mais c'est plutôt
chez les personnes âgées ne visais
plutôt le un public l'aimé patick
ça on ne ressent pas comme ça non ce
qu'on ressent c'est fatigue maux de tête
fièvre éventuellement maux de gorge le
nez bouché perte d'odorat perte de goût
mais évidemment des signes respiratoires
de la toux etc donc quand on a ça il
faut se il est important de se tester
pourquoi c'est important de se tester
parce que
savoir qu'on l'a bon peut-être ça change
pas forcément le traitement si on est
jeune et que vous présentent pas de
signes a rien de spécial à faire ya
toujours pas de traitement dont on
connaît l'efficacité
à prendre pour ses formes précoces après
il ya des choses mais c'est pendant les
hospitalisations mais on on fait ça
pourquoi le faire c'est savoir qu' on
peut transmettre le virus n'est par
exemple
se dire que
dans les jours qui viennent ce n'est pas
le moment d'aller voir les
grands-parents ou telle personne
vulnérable et cetera kg par une personne
qui est suivi au long cours parce que il
a une dialyse parce que l'insuffisance
rénale et c'est le fait de le savoir
parce que généralement quand on va voir
une personne âgée c'est pas pour lui
refiler un virus c'est parce qu'on aime
bien et c'est le fait de le savoir fait
que on va pas faire ça on va pas prendre
ce risque pour les personnes autour et
en fait c'est
je pense que toute personne normalement
constituée
à se dit que c'est mieux de savoir si
elle est contagieuse et si elle est à
risque de transmettre la maladie à son
entourage à ses copains assez
à sa famille à ses collègues
sachant même que transmettre la maladie
quelqu'un sait il cire j'ai un copain
jeunes gis transmet la maladie priori
c'est pas grave sauf que si lui ne sait
pas qu'il vienne vient d'être contaminés
que il va être con il va être contagion
c'est parce qu'il va aller voir après
s'il va pas transmettre la maladie à
quelqu'un qu'ils aiment bien et qui est
fragile
donc sans parler du pas de chance ou
quelqu'un de 30 ou 40 ans peut faire une
forme grave sans avoir de signes
évidents évident ça c'est vraiment pas
de chance mais on peut jamais savoir
quand on contamine quelqu'un si ce
quelqu'un l'a lui ne va pas contaminer
quelqu'un de fragile surtout s'il ne le
sait pas et c'est là que se pose tout le
truc c'est
on n'a pas envie les uns et les autres
de transmettre à notre entourage donc au
moment où on est contaminé
enfin au moment où encore on présente
des signes tout l'intérêt de se tester
et ensuite de voir comment s'isoler il
peut y avoir des aides à lise à
l'isolement-- appelé ya pas mal de
choses nous on avait monté un programme
on y reviendra ça il a pris ses origines
en haïti on avait monté un programme
s'appelle collison pour aider justement
accompagner les malades pour l'
isolement mais le point important c'est
le si moi je sais que je suis positif
est que j'ai vu des personnes par
exemple là on est on est là ensemble et
puis demain après demain je mal à la
tête tout ça je me fais testé je suis
positif parce que je vous le dis est ce
que je vous le dis pas si je vous le dis
pas c'est un sacré connard quand même
parce qu'on est resté là je discute on
est à distance respectable etc
si je vous le dis pas je suis un sacré
connard parce que même si vous me
paraissez pas être des personnes
négatives pour dire il ya trois
personnes devant moi l'assassin
mais ils sont là je le dis quand même
mais ce qu'il dit ffp2 oui masqué avec
des ffp2 m'enfin quand même si je vous
le dit pas et que
vous ne prenez pas de précaution si je
vous le dis vous allez prendre des
précautions en particulier dans vos dans
vos relations et en particulier pour des
personnes vulnérables et vous allez vous
tester au bon moment si je vous le dis
pas vous prenez pas de précautions vous
testez pas vous êtes peut-être
asymptomatique et vous filer le virus à
quelqu'un que vous aimez bien et qui est
fragile
si vous apercevez que c'est moi qui
voulais donner vous allez faire la
gueule
non pas parce que je voulais donner mais
parce que je ne vous ai pas dit alors
que j'avais le temps de vous le dire
avant que vous soyez contagieux donc ce
qui est très important finalement c'est
pas forcément de donner la liste des
noms des contacts à l'assurance maladie
c'est choisir la manière dont ces
personnes vont être prévenus si vous
voulez que ce soit l'assurance maladie
qui le fasse c'est bien si vous préférez
le faire vous même c'est pas mal non
plus
sous réserve que on puisse
expliquer ce qu'il faut faire c'est à
dire que il faut se tester se tester une
autour de à peu près cinq jours une
semaine après le contact et d'ici là
rester extrêmement prudent dans les
interactions sociales je vous coupe je
vous emmène sur un autre sujet le
conseil de défense
qui n'est pas un conseil de guerre même
si nous sommes en guerre comme dirait
notre leader charismatique
notre conseil de défense qui n'est pas
transparent on sait pas ce qui s'y passe
les délibérations c'est
n'a pas de trace
c'est bien c'est pas bien ce que c'est
de la stratégie vaccinale est ce que ça
aide la stratégie de on rassure la
population plus de transparence plus de
confiance donc une stratégie vaccinale
plus effective plus opérationnel
le conseil de défense ont voulu à
proposer on l'a pas proposé
non je crois papier de en fait c'est
tellement c'est opaque donc je ne vois
pas donc je préfère parler de ce que je
connais donc je ne connais pas le
conseil de défense je sais qu'il existe
je sais que des décisions sont prises je
vous me semblait qu'il y avait un
certain nombre de ministres plus le
président j'ai pas le détail de sa
composition et donc je peux
difficilement parler j'aime pas parler
d'un truc que ce qu'on n'est pas bien
ça je vous comprends que mon avis une
commission d' enquête sur le la gestion
de crise oui mais elle a disparu
le jour initie une enquête parlementaire
oui il est là la majorité a dit la
majorité leur om dit monbalen c'est fini
c'est quoi si on casse le thermomètre
pour éviter devant la montée de fièvre
on veut pas se prendre des procès
derrière on veut plus leurs critiques
qui ça sert à rien en fait on gagne ce
n'est pas rien vous n'avez pas non plus
c'est pas là j'ai pas été auditionné par
passer commission denquête ce qui me
choque pas plus que ça c'est ils sont
pas à auditionner tout le monde
et
j'ai regardé quelques trucs comme ça
mais
ça donnerait quoi en bas c'était
intéressant c'est quand c'était raul tu
ça intéresse avoir gardé quand même
c'est un showman oui si différemment du
chou oui donc ça c'était c'était c'était
intéressant pas forcément convaincu par
tous ces arguments mais la manière dont
le tube
dont il a répondu et
c'était particulier donc à regarder oui
mais ça veut pas dire que j'ai suivi de
près le les travaux alors y en avait
deux commissions en avez une au sénat et
une à l'assemblée nationale mais une
seule à l'assemblée nationale qu'il
était dissoute oui et celle du sénat la
deûle a donné quoi vous qu'une idée
donc je peux rien dire dessus parce que
simplement je suis in your hand le
conseil de l'ordre vous le connaissez
sans doute la sottise à sion oui vous
oublie je vais
puis quand vous payez pas vous ils vous
envoient des recommandés et non moi je
paye donc
à voir avec ça sert à quelque chose le
conseil de l'ordre des médecins en 21e
siècle
c'est cher
après
qu'il y ait qui est quelque chose qui
qui suivent un peu sur les points de vue
éthique et ses comportements oui
ce que fait référence vous allez le code
de déontologie parce que tout ça pour
moi tout ça est un peu lié un conseil de
l'ordre de thé anthologie confraternité
etc
j'avoue que j'en ai pas un usage
quotidien ou bien c'est dans les 300 et
quelques noms
faut
[Musique]
vérifier la somme et cc ya pas longtemps
j'ai reçu le papier donc faut que je
paye c'est par mois par an non par an
moi c'est pas mal
ça vous sert à quelque chose ou avoir un
caducée juste on se garde blâme en plus
de je préfère concret c est resté
discret j'ai pas de caducée dans ma
voiture un caducée c'est le
symbole face est une petite chose qu'on
met sur la voiture avec une couleuvre la
couleuvre d'esculape et et pour dire
qu'on est wim bombe
j'ai pas obligé de le dire mais c'est
pas lui le
fait pas des visites à domicile je vais
pas voir ma clientèle etc moi je dirige
un laboratoire
la pitié salpêtrière et je gère la
direction de l'hôpital sur
l'épidémiologie pas besoin d'un cadeau
c'est pour ça vous êtes à la macsf
je crois pas je suis pas très doué là et
à plein de gens qui m'appellent tous les
jours pour demander quelle est ma
mutuelle de le truc et je sais pas et
puis ça m'intéresse pas français je suis
marié
alors il faut pas ajouter du travail et
votre famille ou de choses à faire a
fait fait de l'épidémiologie aussi oui
avec moi n'est pas payé non
ça c'est fait pour lui
les différents vaccins
technologie russe européennes
américaines chinoises
si vous avez le choix si je vous propose
du jour au lendemain je vous dis voilà
sur la table j'ai dû chinois du russe de
l'indien de l'europe et de l'américain
vous signer chez qui je prends un baril
de l'ariel contre de barils non non non
c'est gratuit et pas besoin de trop que
je prendrais pas le chinois pourquoi pas
assez efficace
je prendrai pour l'instant les vaccins
arn les deux là soient le kaiser sur le
moderna parce que cela marche bien
l'anglais le astrazeneca et
par le chinois sera encore moins
efficace nous fait donc c'est pas top
reste le spoutnik 5
je manque de renseignements dessus
mais là c'est clair rien il y en un qui
veut enfin est un type de vaccin qui
valent mieux que les autres c'est les
vaccins événements dans ce qu'on a
actuellement
le professeur à où vous voulez en parler
un petit peu non
pas pourquoi
donc le conseil scientifique voulais en
parler aussi non plus au conseil
scientifique
[Musique]
globalement on peut et on regarde ces
avis étaient plus été plutôt
sensée c'est juste qu'ils n'ont pas été
écoutés après je regrette quand même que
jean françois delfraissy et
paroles malheureuses de dire qu'on
n'était pas une semaine près d'un très
récemment je pense qu'il a peut-être eu
des pressions je ne sais pas en tout cas
[Musique]
voilà c'est un peu dommage mais sinon le
ce qu'ils sont écrits dans les aviser
peut-être pas tous regardé mais on est
regardé pas mal
ça soutient
l'analyse des oublis
est ce que ça fonctionne bien ce que ça
donne dix jours d'avancé ce que
ça fonctionne bien
on se chamaille un peu avec les gens de
l'analyse des eaux lisez pas ce que
ça donne peut-être un peu d'avancé mais
le temps d'avoir les résultats on est à
peu près au même niveau en tout cas
c'est un bon indicateur de
d'effectivement de l'évolution de
l'épidémie y'a pas de ya pas de doute
là-dessus
pourrait
plutôt que deux mais là il ya trouvé des
cas par tous
mais dans une période où beaucoup plus
basse pour être un bon outil de
surveillance pour s'apercevoir vérifier
que n'y a pas quelque chose qui couve
qui est entrain de démarrer
dans ce que c'est un bon truc c'est quoi
un anticorps facilitons
c'est un anticorps qui au lieu de
dix mines de gêner la la survenue de la
maladie va plutôt la facilité
c'est
sable il ya les anticorps bloquant et
puis les anticorps qui finalement ouvre
la porte quelque sorte ce que vous avez
entendu
parler du vaccin contre la dengue oui
c'est ça se passe bien alors il ya
plusieurs formes de dengue 4 forme de
dengue et le problème c'est que ont fait
des formes graves quand on n'a c'est pas
forcément la première dingue mais quand
on fait avec on a eu un premier type est
l'autre après c'est peut-être ça cette
histoire d'un petit corps facilitant
et il s'est trouvé que les essais de
vaccination se sont heurtés face à ce
problème c'est à dire qu'une personne
qui a déjà fait des anticorps contre la
dengue peut faire défendre plus grave et
donc leur accès
alors c'était dans la l'histoire
naturelle de la maladie
mais le dans un essai vaccinal il ya eu
des cas comme ça donc ce top knight
donc c'est ça veut dire que c'est pas
toujours facile de trouver une solution
contre une maladie infectieuse alors il
ya les émirats arabes unis qui ont
approuvé la mission et marché du vaccin
chinois avant même tout le gouvernement
chinois est déjà statué sur son propre
vaccin c'est parce que les émirats
arabes unis sous mon short
ils veulent absolument voir un vaccin
qu'est-ce qui se passe vous connaissez
les émirats arabes unis peut-être pas
voulu peut-être pas en parler je pense
pas au jeu pas de grand chose à dire sur
les émirats arabes unis j'aurais pas
fait ça mais
vous auriez fait quoi j'ai repris le
vaccin chinois parce qu'il n'est pas bon
vous savez pas celui-là maintenant 6 ans
6 alors avant quand on sait pas on prend
pas on ne s'agit pas de prendre un truc
sans savoir s'il est bon ou pas alors
après c'est pas une remise en cause du
fait de de payer tous les fabricants de
vaccins pour que les choses se fassent
et puis de manière à garantir les choses
parce que pour être sûr qu'ils en aient
enfin avoir le maximum de chance comme
un qui soit beau c'est pas là je pense
pas que ce soit les émirats arabes unis
qui est financé la recherche chinoise
pour être sûr qu'ils trouvent axa
only on entend beaucoup de choses avec
la vitamine d le zinc l'ivermectine la
colchicine
et puis faut trier vous triez fautrier
l'ivermectine
il y avait on avait vu ça au printemps
et puis c'est une super public était
sortie qui était en prêt print
qui
qui était soumise
et en fait c'est au moment de l'histoire
de dépublier dans le land 7 sur le new
england journal of medecine sur la
lide roxy chloroquine
et cette sortie juste un peu avant et on
y avait vraiment des résultats très
intéressants une baisse de 80% du nombre
de passages en réanimation c'était
simplement un mois après quand tu as eu
cette histoire là
on a regardé les les noms des auteurs
étaient les mêmes
donc
c'était c'est un fake alors après
beaucoup de pays l'ont quand même
utilisé il ya aucune démonstration que
ça marche d'ivermectine la colchicine
c'est une piste qui quittent explorer
actuelle actuellement la vitamine d j'ai
pas le temps de regarder ces espaces
probablement quelque chose le zinc aussi
mais
on est tellement pris que bon c'est pas
toujours facile
de regarder mais on peut penser qu'il ya
des haies
il ya des choses qui peuvent limiter la
propagation mais j'ai pas de preuves je
sais que l'ivermectine cd fake
et les autres bons la colchicine et une
logique peut-être que ça m'a repoussé
cette histoire de radio militaire et ça
peut ça peut jouer mais il faut faut
bien plus que ce qu'on a pour l'instant
pour dire ça marche passeport vaccinale
est ce que ça sert à quelque chose est
ce que faire un test pcr 24 heures on
prend l'avion ça serra qui font pas la
même chose passeport vaccination c'est
dire qu'on a c'est prouver qu'on a été
vaccinée
c'est pas acceptable
actuellement pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord une raison scientifique c'est
comme ces maps ne sais pas si le cil
vaccin protège des formes
asymptomatiques
on suppose mais ça suffit pas donc on
dire j'ai été vacciné bon on n'a pas la
démonstration
formelle donc faut quand même être être
prudent la deuxième chose c'est que
surtout il ya très peu de vaccins donc
si les gens n'ont pas accès à un vaccin
un vrai problème de leur demander de
prouver qu'ils ont été vaccinées donc le
jour où il y aura beaucoup de vaccins et
qu'on se rassure que ça protège etc on
peut se retrouver dans une situation
assez proche de la médecine des voyages
j'ai un passeport vaccinale déjà
on est toutefois la g1 j'ai un truc de
fièvre jaune il est toujours dans mon
sac au cas où grâce qu'on va faire on
peut le faire à la pitié salpêtrière le
val de grâce c'est fermé c'est vrai
dorilas
c'est un bonus touristes un bono ce taux
après c'est de ces problèmes le service
de santé des armées je peux pas
son bouquin du service de santé des
armées
les civils aussi
non les médecins se sont beaux on a
encore des bons médecins donc maintenant
passeport vaccinale pour combien de
temps les médecins mais jusqu'à ce que
je prenne ma retraite au placement
réussi de passeports vaccinale donc
certainement pas maintenant plus tard
avoir parce que
[Musique]
en tout cas ça existe pour d'autres pour
d'autres maladies
pour prendre l'avion etc la paix serre
avant de prendre l'avion
c'est une sécurité incomplètes on va
dire
je peux prendre l'avion est rentré
d'incuber avant de pensser négative
c'est pas pour ça que quelques jours
après j'amènerai pas le le virus il
voulait savoir si complet ou pas essayer
d'aller en nouvelle zélande ou en chine
vous verrez bien que c'est pas parce que
vous avez une pcr négative au moment de
monter la halle dans l'avion que vous
allez rassurer les autorités chinoises
ont néo zélandaise j'ai pris les deux
pays pour dire que c'est pas que une
histoire de régime vous avez pris le
numéro un dans la gestion de crise était
dans la nouvelle zélande on savait qu
facile quand on est sur une île
oui et donc quand on veut bien géré les
trucs suppose qu'on demande un peu plus
que simple test pcr ou de coller des
petites affichettes dans les aéroports
non réserve oui ça c'était magnifique ça
non correspondance directe avec guan
paris charles de gaulle
et puis on colle des affiches et à
l'arrivée des avions
si vous vous sentez pas bien réveillé
nous le prévenu c'est ça c'est du
foutage de gueule ça quand même non pas
parce qu'on avait perdu l'habitude des
reçus d'accord complètement de ce en
fait je pris l'avion
c'était
début du mois de mars la première
semaine de mars a été à kinshasa pour
travailler avec l'unicef sur la
problématique de la lutte contre le
choléra et des équipes mobiles pour la
lutte contre le choléra comme on l'avait
fait en haïti haïti on a éliminé le
choléra avec des équipes mobiles un peu
comme c'est pour ça que kovy san c'est
une histoire de l'équipe mobile et tout
ça et qu'on l'a commencée sur cette base
là et en rentrant de cette semaine de
travail je pensais trouver un pays sur
le pied de guerre effectivement et il y
avait rien du tout on était le 8 mars y
avait rien du tout et il m'a fallu
quelques jours pour pouvoir
finalement donné l' alerte et va
retrouver dans le but non bureau de
martin hirsch directeur de l'ap-hp et le
convaincre que on allait se prendre
quelque chose de terrible et c'est là où
c'est cette période là où tout a basculé
je suis pas le seul à avoir donné l
alerte mais qui heureusement quelques
personnes ont donné l alerte et ont
fait réfléchir et veiller un peu nos
politiques que les pandémies ça existait
vraiment
il sentit nos politiques en mode ronron
quotidien
on avait pas de vent de ça il était dans
le déni c'est une fête où je sais pas si
j'ai beaucoup de doha ou pas mais à
distance je suis pas du tout capable de
sentir les politiques qui les
fréquentent pas
c'est pas mal la blague
je les connaissais pas maintenant j'ai
été amené à voir quelques personnes mais
à l'époque je n'avais aucune raison que
moi avec mes antécédents de lutte contre
le choléra ou contre d'autres maladies
sous les tropiques
j'intéresse qui que ce soit dans les
parmi les politiques donc vous les avez
un peu machine goûter
quel goût c'est digest sa part il vient
pas beaucoup de goût non manque un peu
de noms mais je sais pas anthropophage
unis coprophages ni coprophages non plus
on va prendre quelques questions
internet ouais on essaye aller
attention je vais pas pouvoir tout
prendre légal et puis les filles je
prends au hasard
alors salué ces bonnes questions
alors pourquoi entends ton le créateur
des tests pcr qui aurait déconseillé de
les utiliser pour détecter un malade
non les tests pcr s'est s'est approprié
pour pour le diagnostic c'est les tests
anti gêné qui peuvent être qu'on
n'utilise pas par exemple on va pas
faire un diagnostic si quelqu'un vient
l'hôpital on va pas lui faire un test
antigénique pour le négoce et ça c'est
les tests rapides alors le le le mais
les tests pcr c'est ceux qui sont
utilisés alors le j'ai dû voir ça de la
communauté blâmer envoyé pour préparer
l'émission on voit un mec dire qu'avec
l'été ce pc on peut répliquer
des boues qui se balader en fin de
compte on se retrouve avec
des gros gros bout si on réplique plus
de soixante mille fois oui alors un test
pcr sas interprète
donc
fait c'est un système d'amplification
donc effectivement on double x x et donc
c'est le nombre de cycles
d'amplification qui compte
jusqu'à 33 34 35 cycle d'amplification
ça a du sens après effectivement s'il a
le truc de la pcr commence à monter mais
très très tardivement on considère que
c'est négatif alors si quelqu'un ne fait
pas gaffe et continue donc c'est tout le
job d'interpréter mais c'est
c'est un bon test à condition d'être
correctement fait est correctement
interprété destin annales
c'est la nouveauté c'est simplement
portent le virus un peu plus longtemps
dans l'intestin
donc pour faire du diagnostic sanaa ça
n'a pas d'intérêt particulier enfin
c'est quand même
je veux bien qu'on me dise aux gens
c'est votre pantalon je vous met un
écouvillon mais nous ya dessus il ya
d'autres moyens de faire connaissait pas
la vague le bug du gastro entérologue
non
c'est pas ces listes de gastro voilà ces
deux jeux ces deux vieux qui vont voir
un gastro entérologue le mec je sais pas
s'il a quitté sanaa
bon finalement c'est pas la paix alors
qu'elle est selon lui le pays qui gère
le mieux le coronavirus vous voulez la
blague donc le vieux va chez son gastro
entérologue le gastro-entérologue
lumière petit doigt comme d'habitude et
la paix pays fait
l'intérieur sud derrière le rideau il à
sa femme qui lui dit tu vois chez les
cht avait dit que ça faisait mal
quel est selon lui le pays qui gère le
mieux le coronavirus
faible pour la gestion nouvelle zélande
numéro deux après
en deuxième le vietnam
pourquoi c'est là aux résultats qu'ils
ont obtenus
quand il ya madagascar qui dit voilà on
a l'artemisia ont fait une otite et ça
marche bien vous en pensez quoi alors
bon je pense que ça marche pas
premièrement mais surtout ça permet de
dire quelque chose
un argument qui est volontiers présenté
comme quoi en afrique il n'ya pas de ya
pas de kobe d'où vient ma très peu parce
que les gens prennent
de la chloroquine alors les ans ça fait
belle lurette que
la chloroquine on ne marche pas bien sûr
le palu puisqu'on ne prennent pas tous
les jours même s'il ya quelques endroits
où ils en prennent au moment d'un accès
palustre ce qui serait pas une bonne
idée ça beaucoup de résistance c'est pas
ça qui les protègerait au quotidien
contre contre lacko vide par contre en
afrique le mode de vie est pas le même
le quand même beaucoup plus à
l'extérieur
dans les espaces beaucoup plus aéré les
pyramides des âges ne rien avoir et ça
fait que et puis certainement des cas
qui est passée inaperçue donc il ya peu
de vieux
peu de transports en commun il ya un peu
doux baez a commencé en avoir donc du
sud tout ça oui tout ça fait que dans
l'ensemble quand même il ya beaucoup
moins de cas moi je suis pas allé en
jeu il ya l'afrique mais rien qu'en
guyane on on y étaient au moment de avec
un collègue médecin on est allé
installer des équipes mobiles justement
fin de l'accompagnement de patients à la
demande de la rs on est allé dans un
dans un
petite ville typique bourgade 15000
habitants
en plein coeur de la guyane dans la
forêt là moi j'étais le pépère le pépère
de chez pépère puisque 7 % de la
population à plus de 45 ans
moi avec mes 60 ans suis vraiment
l'ancêtre donc les quelques personnes
âgées bon
réfléchir comment faire en sorte enfin
de faire passer le message d'éviter de
d'être en contact avec mais ce qui est
important à avoir c'est que quand on a
un fait c'était mon collègue qui
s'appelle cette année ça ce mode est il
là il a fait les calculs de risques de
décès en fonction de la pyramide des
âges et le risque globalement sur ce
patelin de maripasoula étaient onze fois
moins important que en france
métropolitaine
simplement tenant compte des âges donc
parce que le lac au vide tu beaucoup
plus des personnes âgées que des
personnes jeunes et
donc là c'est pas une question et c'est
un commentaire et d'ailleurs je vais en
profiter pour dire ne fait pas de
commentaires dans la zone question donc
c'est un commentaire qui dit 75 mille
morts sur 60 millions c'est pas les
cathos non plus faut arrêter ces
soixante quinze mille morts
malgré un certain nombre de mesures qui
ont été prises qui était quand même
extrêmement sévère c'est pas une
hécatombe mais c'est quand même plus de
sur une année ça sur un peu plus d'une
année là les soixante quinze mille mots
mais c'est
sur une année on est à peu près à 600
mille morts donc on est à + 10 % des
morts d'une année et c'est en tout cas
beaucoup plus que la grippe que plein de
plein d'autres maladies mais
effectivement on peut faire ce choix
alors si on fait rien c'est pas 75000
mans mais on est on parle en centaines
de milliers de morts c'est là le
problème c'est éviter d'avoir ce nombre
là pour moi 75 morts quand même ça ça
représente beaucoup
mais non du tabac en france bon le
cancer du poumon que la le pr la
première le premier cancers liés au
tabac bien à d'autres
c'est trente mille morts les morts du
tabac
ouais peut-être ça va être un truc dans
le même ordre de grandeur
mais c'est beaucoup aussi
les accidents de la route c'est 3000
donc
je sais pas
est-ce que vous avez vu le
un truc qui s'appelle hold up oui vous
l'a eu oui de a à z oui je ne fais pas
fait trop chi
c'est mon métier de regarder ça
non c'est important de le regarder
j'en ai tiré la conclusion que ce qui
était c'est que il ils ont utilisé un
certain nombre de faits c'est toujours
un mélange de vrai et de faux insectes
peut-être oui et ce mélange de vrai et
de faux fait que on peut quand même
regretter un certain nombre de choses
qui sont passées pendant sa vie vendée
ont soulevé des questions légitimes dont
c'est ça et aussi
ce qui est malheureux c'est ensuite d'en
tirer des conclusions
qui sont voilà beaucoup il ya des choses
fausses et ensuite ça de ça déraille qu
en quelque sorte mais il ya du vrai de
dans lequel parti était vrai
le problème de des big pharmas et est un
vrai problème
mais moi je peux en rajouter allez c'est
comme ça ça le on a un problème en ont
parlé de bill gates
on a parlé de bill gates quoi ils ont
parlé de bill gates sais pas comment on
va parler ici bill gates
dans le choléra en haïti a voulu
imposer une
une stratégie vaccinale
sa fondation
en 6e lui même enfin c'est davantage une
fondation c'est qu'il ya pas de comité
d'entreprise enfin c'est c'est encore
plus c'est plus de pouvoir c'est
vraiment lui même c'est vraiment son
truc l'idée alors bill gates sur le sur
le vaccin choléra d'abord via un fonds
d'investissement
avec la morgan chase bank il possède des
usines de vaccins encore et qui font un
vaccin pour le choléra en 2016 et eu un
gros cyclone en haïti et ce vaccin c'est
un vaccin qui venait tout juste d'être
pré qualifiés par l'om et bill gates
quand même finances la global task force
for choléra contrôle de sélection fait
partie pas de bill gates mais de la
global 24 ans donc je vois bien que les
choses france 1000 gates est le
partenaire aussi le premier partenaire
privé dans le gavi c'est un fonds
mondial pour la vaccination donc ils
sont surtout les trucs et ils ont voulu
imposer et lancer une campagne de
vaccination
mais avec ce nouveau vaccin est sûr
d'une nouvelle modalité c'était une dose
plutôt que de faire deux doses et
ça s'est fait comme ça mais sans
vraiment que enfin on sent que c'était
une expérimentation à très large échelle
willow mais j'ai eu quand même quelques
et en particulier vous pouvez en oui et
en particulier mais je les écris réécrit
dans un livre s'appelle choléra
utilisions ses nerfs et sédition sont
pas des c'est pas des éditeurs a publié
il avait pour préparer cette campagne de
vaccination produit des figures bidonné
c'était une université américaine
c'était mal tomber parce qu' il s' était
parti d'une figure originale que vous
avez pris sur internet dont la
connaissance des noms que l'avion fait
pas de bol et donc
ça a été l'occasion de s'engueuler sur
ce sur ce sujet il ya une vraie
polémique sur cette histoire de
vaccination mais je vais plus loin deux
ans après parce qu'il ya quand même un
peu de financement ce qu'on a pu mettre
des équipes mobiles il ya plus de
choléra en haïti et bill gates mais 10
millions pour une campagne de
vaccination jeu quelques quelques
semaines avant la fin de du choléra
parce qu'ils y croyaient pas parce que
c'est cette histoire vient cette
histoire de choléra environnementale et
imedi millions j'ai la lettre qu'il
écrit il écrit à la ministre de la santé
en disant donne 10 millions pour ça et
10 pouces pour une campagne de
vaccination évidemment entre temps le
choléra sight
il pour continuer à pousser la campagne
de vaccination il finance des équipes de
recherche pour faire de la modélisation
pour dire que la seule manière d'obtenir
de d'obtenir l'élimination du choléra en
haïti c'est de faire une grande campagne
de vaccination
et ces équipes là oublient de dire qu'il
ya plus de choléra en haïti ils ont
publié ça dans une des revues du 27 et
nous avons fait une lettre de réponse
très récemment ça s'est passé donc plus
d'un an après il y avait plus et dans la
réponse ils disent oui mais peut-être
que le système de santé l'a pas des mets
dans l'article ne m'a même pas qu'il ya
plus de cas de choléra le choléra est
éliminé en maths en inde et laisse un
délai de 3 ans née sur deux ans il faut
encore un an + n'y a pas eu un seul cas
de choléra en haïti et ça n'empêche pas
des publications de se faire dans alors
c'est je crois que c'est lent c'est
global health ou silence est public
health est l'un des deux est une
publication modélisation quatre équipes
trois équipes payé par la fondation
gates la quatrième est en plus
indépendantes pour travailler sur le
truc tous des 10 il faut vacciner à fond
pour obtenir l'élimination ce truc là
est paru dans une très bonne revue ils
ont juste oublié de dire qu'ils avaient
plus de colère en haïti
tranquille
et à la fin dans les conflits d'intérêts
le truc a pas de conflit d'intérêts mais
financement remercie la fondation gates
qui possède les usines de vaccins
font mal quand même non
donc il ya quand même des choses en face
de moi j'ai le spécialiste mondial du
choléra qui me balance ainsi
tranquillement sur sa chaise
en gros il avait du vaccin ils ont
financé des études pour pour écluser
leurs vaccins ils veulent créer un
marché du vaccin ça c'est pas pour
balancer le match de vaccin parce qu'il
savait pas comment faire c'est pour
pour populariser donc ils ont assez mal
réussi en haïti il ya eu cette histoire
du cyclone idea au mozambique
c'était il ya un gros cyclone
réchauffement climatique machin derrière
cas de diarrhée ou là là on a trouvé du
choléra le vaccin arrive à fond la
caisse ils vaccine et dans les jours qui
viennent qui suivent le choléra
s'écroule tout le monde pense que c'est
le vaccin mais c'est pas possible parce
qu'on sait que le délai pour
obtenir une immunité c'est après la
deuxième dose et ça prend enfin voilà
faux frères là c'était quelques jours
c'est il avait même pas finie la
récession une semaine avait pas même pas
filer la semaine de la campagne de
vaccination que déjà ça c'est cool et
tout le monde est persuadé les gens qui
reviennent du terrain croit il croit que
c'est le vaccin qu'il a fait c'est juste
impossible donc c'est très très facile
de faire croire que un truc fonctionne
ou pas mais ça c'est des vrais histoire
c'est pas la peine de rajouter des
fossiles y en a des vrais
dont convient hold up
donc en 10 % étaient légitimes a soulevé
des questions légitimes et le reste
c'était du yaourt
je saurai pas mettre un pourcentage je
l' ai vu à l'époque l'épave mais il y
avait des choses légitime l'avait
dépouillée questionnement légitime oui
et il y avait des effets qu il y avait
les deux une autre question légitime
qu'ils ont pu soulever c'était quoi
redites mans les choses et je dirais
c'était légitime ou pas gestion des
masques légitime
position du politique
il ya des choses légitime big pharma des
choses légitime bon et après j'ai arrêté
parce que c'était dû eux aussi
tout regarder mais après voilà c'est un
peu compliqué et c'est le mélange et
c'est
globalement il ya une intention de
tromper
vous pensez braderie quand même
autre question d'internet un avis sur la
situation suédoise et en particulier à
stockholm
peut-être pas être très précis
la situation suédoises
sont à peu près au même niveau que nous
en terme de mortalité
donc je dirais pas dire que c'est une
une réussite mortalité nombre de morts
par million d'habitants donc je ne peux
pas dire c'est une réussite parce que je
trouve pas qu'on soit qu'on est con
effet une réussite c'est beaucoup plus
que les pays
autour
suède norvège danemark c'est comme la
suède cadets où la finlande aussi la
suède qu'elle est résultat les les pires
je crois qu'ils sont vraiment largement
revenus de
de leur gestion initiale est missionné
d'ailleurs je sais pas s'il a
démissionné mais il a reconnu qu'il
s'était trompé et haut finira jamais en
france d'ailleurs c'est ça sera
intéressante et je serai surpris donc
ils sont ils sont plus tard revenu à une
manière plus classique
de gérer même si alors on va dire que
encore des cinémas ou vers des choses
comme ça mais c'est pas tous les cinémas
c'est pas n'importe quoi enfin et
globalement ils ont quand même des
résultats qui sont plutôt nettement
moins bon il faut bien tenir compte de
la localisation géographique
on peut difficilement avoir des bons
résultats quand les voisins ont des
mauvais on peut avoir des mauvais
résultat qu'on est voisin des bons mais
ça arrive à faire ça mais quand même
globalement
les endroits où il ya eu des la forte de
transmission forte transmission et
beaucoup de brassage de population
évidemment que c'est les résultats sont
finalement mélange est donc toute la
partie europe de l'ouest extrêmement
touchée il n'y a pas un pays qui s'en
sort vraiment bien
par contre dans les pays du nord la
suède est quand même le pays qui
s'enterre le moins bien
question qui ne voient qu'une question
le coït 19 affecte-t-il la fertilité
chez l'homme comme le suggère le
national librairie of medecine du
national institute of science je sais
pas c'est possible mais j'ai pas j'ai
pas regardé cette question la fumigation
dans les rues en chine ça sert à quelque
chose qui passe avec leur qu'elle voit
fumer là
les cannois fumée les camions qui
diffuse des
je vois parfois je sais pas je n'ai pas
vu son chine mais je ne suis pas tout le
temps en chine ce pas non je sais pas je
sais pas ce qu'il faut que je sache ce
qui mettrait non je sais pas ce que
c'est
imaginez-vous il mettant désinfectant
longue date mon nom mais j'imagine les
images et je peux pas dire ce que c'est
ça tient la route ce genre de choses je
ne sais pas j'en viens au métro oui on
va pas vous parler du métro
bon alors si on parle pas comme le
recommande l'académie de médecine
si si on n'est pas trop série on peut
continuer d'aller travailler pendant
qu'on finance
pour qu'on soit pas trop serré fauqué le
minimum de personnes qui avaient
travaillé dans l'est dans les jours les
semaines qui viennent c'est en un an une
période difficile à passer
si on fait tout comme ont fait jusqu'à
maintenant
la montée va être vraiment rude donc
falloir changer quelque chose
le confinement c'est maintenant une
montre dans le métro moins de monde dans
le métro mais ptet 7 mai de la revue
tous nous
et attend même des gens qui doivent
venir travailler est-ce qu'il faut
mettre dans les hôpitaux dans les
niveaux mettre des lunettes
pour aller dans métro +1 est fait par ma
connaissance ne voit pas le ca aurait
quand même un intérêt non sauf si vous
avez problèmes de vue non mais des
lunettes ceux des vizirs non mais non
non non le plaisir ça marche pas non pas
les visions mais des
trucs de ce riz dans les trous ce qui
m'autorise cabines ont fait la blague
pourquoi pause qui
pourquoi le gouvernement interdit
d'ouvrir la station de ski c'est un peu
du foutage de gueule non alors le fait
d'aller skier probablement pas ce prix
doté de 7 juin déjà il ya des gens qui
vont qui viennent donc ensuite je pense
qu'on n'y va jamais tout seul on y va
avec les copains ensuite on est
peut-être dans des petits appartements
ou des choses comme ça les hôtels c'est
peut-être un peu fermé je ne sais pas
trop comment enfin il faut manger manger
et à tout ce qui augmente les mouvements
c'est pas des risques énormes et surtout
pas limité c'est ce même chose pour le
cinéma c'est la même chose pour tout ce
qu'on veut faut pas limiter au seul on
va au ski oui quand on fait du ski on
n'attrape pas la qu'ovide
quand on fait la queue
peut-être on la trappe quand on est à 12
copains dans un truc avec trois pièces
c'est quand même beaucoup tient le
premier cluster qu'on a eu en france
c'est mon jeu voilà contamine c'était
des gens qui étaient venus faire du ski
mais c'étaient des anglais non c'est un
anglais oui mais c'est je veux dire
deuxième c'est l'été quoi c'était l'armé
non l'oise c'est énorme et c'est l'oise
où je lui dis très très accrue mais vous
n'allez pas dire que c'était l'armée
pense que c'est ça a quand même mais
c'est quand même un peu plus beau
réclamer genre partie des gens n'ont pas
ce qu'ils veulent pas dire que c'était
l'armée au départ il fallait surtout pas
dire que c'était l'armée
c'est pas moi qui fais l'investigation
les éléments que qu'on a sont assez en
faveur de cette hypothèse
je vous ai coupé
aller au ski c'est quand même plein de
choses dont donc pas c'est aussi une
journée entière dans la bagnole ou un
truc comme ça
enfin il ya ça augmente quand même
beaucoup les les risques de
contamination les risques d'être en
présence avec quelqu'un en milieu
confiné et c'est donc c'est comme le
reste est allé au cinéma oui si je vais
au cinéma tout seul si on sale gosse se
regroupe on fait pas la queue devant 6
etc oui ça peut tout à fait marcher le
problème là c'est qu'on a besoin de
ralentir l'épidémie actuellement le jour
où les choses iront peut mieux faut
lâcher un peu mais actuellement c'est
pas le moment de rajouter même des
petites occasions de transmission il ya
une question un peu provoc qui dit la
question internet la grippe a disparu
grâce aux gestes barrières mais là que
vite pour grèce à cause du non respect
des gestes-barrières est ce logique
la grippe est beaucoup moins contagieuse
que la laque ovide et en particulier le
nouveau variant est encore plus
contagieux donc effectivement pour les
défenseurs de la grippe faut se rebeller
vite fait parce que le prend mal
mais on va pas défendre la grippe a pour
l'heure question internet qu'elle
regarde porte-t-il sur l'état de
l'industrie pharmaceutique en france de
la recherche et de l'outil de production
de la recherche à l'outil de production
vaste question
je suis
beaucoup plus favorable à une recherche
publique que au crédit impôt recherche
alors se faire vacciner alors qu'on a
déjà eu la cour vide pourquoi se faire
alors moi c'est pour qu'on ne dise pas
que j'ai peur du vaccin parce que sinon
c'est pas possible donc quand je me suis
fait vacciner c'est au moment personne
ne voulait se faire vacciner donc j'y
suis allé ça fait un rappel
après
considère que c'est vrai que les doses
de vaccins ce serait quand même au mieux
les réserver aux personnes qui en a fait
la couv id
question pour monsieur piarroux quid de
l' agence européenne des médicaments et
de sa crédibilité fiabilité entre
parenthèses vaccin américain johnson and
johnson fiable à 66% selon l' annonce de
l'entreprise mais tout donné prévu pour
une raison de 200 millions de 12 en
union européenne d'ici juin je pense que
66 % ce n'est pas très différente
d'astrazeneca
donc c'est pour ça que ce quand vous me
demandez quel vaccin g choisir et c'est
pas forcément celui là
dans une situation où on manque de
vaccins et c'est une possibilité qu'un
se marrant parce que 66 pension c'est
aussi l'efficacité du vaccin choléra de
doses on est autour de 60 et quelques
pour cent donc il y à des vaccins qui
sont pas deux de très bonne qualité
ça peut aider quand même
ça peut limiter d'abord les formes
graves ça peut
être
intéressant pour
asseoir une immunité de groupe mais
c'est sûr que quand il y en a qui sont
efficaces à 95 points sens préfère cela
je pense de la rémunération à l'acte
pour qu'elle fait pour qu elle
c'est vrai que je peux pas demander de
complément en tout cas pour certaines
activités on doit par exemple propose
repense aux équipes mobiles ont de
passer du temps à expliquer les choses
il vaut mieux que ce soit la vacation
c'est à dire à la demi-journée ou à la
journée qu'à l'acte parce que
ben voilà c'est si c'est pour faire à
toute vitesse c'est pas bon donc selon
les cas quand c'est un acte très précis
etc ça marche pensez du relationnel etc
il vaut mieux prendre un peu plus de
temps question internet quels sont ses
sources pour dire que leur exemple
fighter est efficace par des
publications dont une publication dans
le new england journal of medecine qui
est paru et à peu près un mois
c'est en anglais mais des traducteurs si
vous voulez enfin nous on sait on sait
lire l'anglais donc il ya une étude avec
des personnes vaccinées des personnes
non vaccinées ils ont calculé longue
alors c'est efficace contre les formes
symptomatiques on ne sait pas on n'a pas
encore les résultats contre les formes
asymptomatiques dû à la méthodologie de
recherche et le résultat c'est une
efficacité vaccinale à 95% pour refaire
les calculs ça marche
question internet
un avis sur le visage du pooling pour
dépister massivement
le problème nous a pressés alors il ya
deux approches de poulina langue pulling
c'est de mélanger les prélèvements d'eau
de plusieurs personnes voire d'une
centaine de personnes il y en a qui vont
jusque là pour regarder c'est un positif
au milieu donc c'est sa part du principe
que la pcr est extrêmement sensible on
met un positif par me sens négatif ça
sortira positif mais après qu'est ce
qu'on fait alors on décompose le le truc
finalement
ça derrière la question c'est est ce
qu'on peut tester tout le monde en même
temps
sauf que même si on arrivait à tester
avec de pooling peut-être on pourrait
tester tout le monde en même temps sauf
quand on dirait parmi ces sens là il y
en a qui est positif alors après on fait
quoi block en bloc sans personne pour un
positif c'est pas jouable on refait des
tests pcr dans ce cas là on perd un
temps fou et donc en pratique après on
peut le dépistage massif on n'arrive pas
à le faire parce que il ya tout
l'accompagnement du dépistage qui ne
marche pas alors là c'est une question
vous avez peut-être pas pour nous
répondre c'est une question vie privée
mais mes joues l'impôt ce camp mais il
est important de traquer le virus mais
cela ne peut-il pas donner des outils de
traque des individus qui eux seront
potentiellement toujours là après la
maladie est-ce que vous avez un avis sur
cette question là c'est pour ça que dans
le
dans le traçage quand d'abord bon c'est
vrai que la base va être effacées etc
mais si quelqu'un a pas envie sur le
comprend très bien d'aller dire qu'il
était
chez sa maîtresse ou n'importe où enfin
son maître chez son maître dans
que ce soit une histoire de sexualité ou
n'importe n'ai pas envie de dire où il
est allé terra
il s'est quand même où il est allé et
moi je pense qu'il faut laisser
la possibilité aux personnes de faire
même la démarche de prévenir les
contacts donc on peut passer ça peut
être des fois on préfère ne pas trop se
mettre en vue en prévenant les contacts
par exemple au travail et vous mieux que
ce soit l'assurance maladie qui disent
vous êtes contact de quelqu'un sans
savoir qui c'est donc ça peut être
intéressant de passer par une
administration comme ça on reste anonyme
dans d'autres cas on apprend on préfère
prévenir nous mêmes moi j'ai été trois
fois contact jamais ça à était
l'assurance maladie c'est les gens qui
m'ont dit on s'est vus il ya deux jours
je suis positif
j'avais vu sur les questions de variants
une minute une vidéo de votre ancien
collègue professeur ou qu'ils aient les
variants ont émergé là on a utilisé du
raid des civils
alors les variantes ont déjà émergé très
tôt puisque au départ il y avait deux
variants là qui ont diffusé dans pas mal
de pays il y en a un qui a complètement
disparu et donc celui qu'ont acquis et
le classique actuellement est déjà un
qui a pris le dessus sur
sur un autre là il n'y avait pas
vraiment de de pression
ce qu'il dit les variants ils
apparaissent ils apparaissent déjà parce
que probablement parce que des gens qui
ont des portages assez prolongée donc ça
laisse le temps dans ses variantes
d'émerger avec beaucoup de mutations ce
que dit didier raoul tu sais que en
donnant la fois des anticorps plus leur
haine des civils qui auraient une une
action mutagènes finalement on se met
dans des conditions positives plus
favorable à l'émergence d'un paresseux
barrios et tient la route non c'est une
hypothèse
on sait que le règne de suivre sa marche
pas donc on va arrêter ça mais je ne
connais pas assez le fonctionnement du
réel des civières pour savoir si
si c'est vrai que ça crée plus de
mutations
c'est juste une hypothèse et
deuxièmement est ce que c'est ça qui a
provoqué c'est encore une hypothèse donc
j'ai pas j'ai pas de réponse je dirais
simplement que c'est une hypothèse qu'il
arrange parce que ça lui permet de deux
cas c'est de casser du gip du gilead
donc il ya ce truc là mais
le mécanisme se serait l'un donne des
mutations l'autre sélectionne les
mutations alors ce qui est intéressant
là dedans c'est quand même dans la
stratégie vaccinale attention de pas
trop traîner dans la mise en place des
vaccins parce que si on a la foi des
vaccins et une très forte circulation du
virus est bien le virus il va se dire
peut-être qu'il va s'adapter enfin
passer chez quelques personnes vaccinées
et c'est quand même des circonstances on
peut imaginer que des résistances
apparaissent donc des modifications
attention ne sait pas on n'en n'a pas
fini entre la bataille entre vaccin à
virus
la question je m'apprêtais à vous poser
qui était quid des mutations qui
pourrait rendre dès les vaccins mot
efficace voire inefficaces comme on
évolue t-il ce risque donc c'est un
risque réel avec simplement une une
chose
intéressante
c'est qu'on a été assez vite pour faire
les vaccins et maintenant que les choses
sont lancées pour faire des passes qu'on
peut faire des vaccins mutants dans
quelque sorte de vaccins contre les
mutants donc il ya un moment il y aura
une course à faire entre les deux
il ya des questions il y en a il ya bien
il y en a bien un même bien beaucoup des
questions aujourd'hui
est ce que vous voyez tout jugé qu on
n'a pas abordé encore ça fait déjà
beaucoup de sujets on va faire les
questions aux fritons alors
l'alcool le tabac est ce que ça protège
de quelque chose avec le co vide on dit
que les fumeurs de choc malkovich que ce
qui se met
alors est ce que c'est le tabac ça
serait peut-être la nicotine
il ya quelque chose protecteur
cela dit je veux pas me faire un cancer
du poumon pour éviter de choper
alors à ma connaissance
alcool piste avant ses 364 morts par
jour beaucoup ne confirme pas cela ça se
transmet pas c'est ça voilà c'est parce
que ça se transmet pas
enfin après qu'on ait un fils louis est
ce qu est ce qu on a une politique très
logique en ce qui concerne le tabac je
suis pas sûr est ce que ça vaut vraiment
coup de laisser
vendre du tabac pendant beaucoup
d'impôts pour que je sais pas c'est pas
c'est pas de tout ce qu'il ya de plus
pertinent comme politique de santé
publique mais c'est pas contagieux de la
même manière et pas besoin de s'isoler
vous voyez la situation commande ou
trois mois
dans nos trois mois on sera passé par
deux trois mois difficiles et j'espère
que ça ira mieux il ya plus si plusieurs
raisons la première c'est l'immunisation
et surtout l'immunisation à cause de la
maladie actuellement on a
200 mille nouveaux cas diagnostiqués par
semaine si on rajoute qu on en
diagnostic peut-être qu'une qu'une
fraction c'est peut-être six cent mille
huit cent mille par semaine le vaccin
nous en livrera peut-être les bonnes
semaines 500 mille doses dont claude
250000 personnes vaccinées donc sur un
million de personnes immunisées y en
aura deux cent cinquante mille avec le
vaccin 750 milles avec le la maladie
donc il va y avoir plus de gens
immunisés donc ça finira par faire
plafonner l'épidémie ce qu'on ne sait
pas c'est à quel moment ça va se faire
ensuite il y aura le printemps on sait
que maintenant que le virus est sensible
aux saisons donc ça va aller mieux ça on
ira vers le mieux on aura pris encore
une mauvaise vague dans la gueule vous
avez évoqué le diagnostic par
intelligence artificielle
donc ça oui mais c'est pas pour fait pas
trouvé de d'indications très très forte
dans le dans le la problématique du coc
vite c'était c'est sur d'autres choses
c'est pour apprendre à identifier les
agents pathogènes ou des choses comme ça
enfin c'est c'est des trucs très
spécialisés ou reconnaître dès le
paludisme sur un frottis sanguins se
mettre ce qu'on y travaille
question internet que pense monsieur
piarroux de louis fouchy docteur louis
foucher porte-parole de riz un foucault
vide ouais je connais très bien louis
vu passer le bonjour bonjour louis
bonjour louis bonjour carole karl sa
femme elle était mon
travail dans mon labo quand j'étais à
marseille donc
je suis triste de la manière dont
il a viré très très complotistes
et surtout il se fait du mal c'est quand
même
voilà il a une vision des choses et
s'est embarqué dans une histoire je
pense qu'ils y croient mais s'est
assombri la vue quand même donc ça me
fait de la peine
si vous dis ok boomer
s'il me dit quoi ou qui est beau mur et
ça veut dire lire tes vieux tu sais plus
rien à alors moi je suis de la
génération d'après non il m'a pas du
tout dit ça au début on a même eu un
échange de mails comme il sait ce que
j'ai fait sur haïti et ses
salons j'ai l'impression que ça allait
un peu secoué mais après non non c'est
pas faut que j'aille rediscuter avec lui
mais j'ai peur que ce soit compliqué
après il ya toujours des choses
intéressantes dans ce qu'il dit mais il
va trop loin quand
sow par rapport justement là le fait
de pas prendre des mesures quand on en
est dans une situation comme maintenant
est ce que c'est de la com la seconde
dose à six semaines un avis
c'est les anglais qui avait repoussé la
seconde dose
ça fait un peu yoyo c'est maintenant
elle est plus à six semaines elle est
redescendue à quatre semaines ou trois
semaines ou quatre semaines selon les
indications
en fait on sait pas bien si ça fait une
différence
le
de manière assez banal quand
tant que pédiatre quand il ya le
quelqu'un a pris du retard dans son
calendrier de vaccination
ben on reprend là où il a laissé donc
hausse c'est pas grave c'est un espace
entre deux doses mais là ils ont l'air
de tenir quand même à rester à 3 4
semaines faut demander plus précisément
moi ça me paraissait pas très inquiétant
de faire a dit à six semaines sauf que
une dose ne protège pas bien donc
finalement ça ça laisse prise de temps
votre les gens soient protégés mais s'il
faut demander à vraiment des
spécialistes du vaccin alors les gars
disent il al'avantage de l'intelligence
collaborative et horizontale je me fait
corriger par corps tout fart s qui dit
sky raoult cité john l'oni disque idées
bonnes que le confinement le nom le
number one des épidémiologistes h factor
200 de standford
faut pas trop se fier c'est le genre de
chose sinon
le hb facteur de dire out est aussi de
cet ordre là mais c'est à propos de quoi
du confinement oui il disait que
confinement ça servait à rien que ça
faisait plus de cas qu autre chose parce
qu'on finit les gens dans une même
structure familiale dans un
environnement cloud donc les gens
s'échangent et le début du confinement
en mars ya certaines règles la
transmission intrafamiliale
mais c'était parti dans une telle
dynamique que la transmission ailleurs
devait être aussi arrêté finalement il
ya quand même la honte c'est très clair
ce qui suit les jambes
peuvent peuvent aller regarder la
dynamique entre l'épidémie est les pics
épidémiques et les les confinements
dégager dix jours quinze jours après les
décisions de q2 voilà de fermer les
collèges les lycées peut-être les écoles
de diminuer le nombre de personnes dans
les transports en commun cesser ces
résultats-là intermédiaires qu'il faut
atteindre pour diminuer la la pression à
la propagation du virus je ne sais pas
quelles sont les décisions prises et
c'est peut-être là il devait prendre les
décisions ce soir j'ai pas sûr
il ya plus de vidéos ou les gars là
pourquoi disent qu'il ya plus de vidéos
c'est un bug du tube on va
régler ça on arrive à la fin notre vidéo
notre interview est-ce que vous avez
trois livres a conseillé à notre
communauté
sur le chemin importe quoi
c'est bon c'est revenu le seigneur des
anneaux tom un terme de temps que trois
vous avez vu ça bah ouais j'aime bien ça
non mais ouais
le doute n'aura d'autre part de padoue
tivo que je n'ai jamais écrit de
bouquins sur l'épidémie l'arrière sur
haïti je conseille celui sur haïti
assure un suivi sur haïti or comment
s'appelle haïti histoire d'un désastre
est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations
une bouteille à la mer quelque chose
d'un périssables
de là il faut il faut patienter il faut
pas s'énerver
là c'est pas le moment de s'énerver et
le joueur faudra s'énerver je m'en
servais comment
faudra demander des comptes à la fin
mais à la fin
vous invitera pour ça
j'ai pas la jeune génération sur ok
boomer où ça y est j'ai compris
professeur piarroux merci de rien
[Musique]